[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning all right do we have any
preliminary matters before
okay
sure
all right are we ready for the jury then
all right
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen please be seated all right
your next witness yes good morning your
honor uh mr depp calls officer tyler
hadden and ladies and gentlemen of the
jury the first part of the testimony you
will hear is questioning uh by miss
heard's counsel and then we'll let you
know when mr depp's counsel takes over
the question all right thank you by
deposition thank you
please state your name and your business
address
tyler padden
one five four six
west martin luther king jr boulevard
los angeles california
what is your occupation
i'm a police officer for the city of los
angeles
and how long have you been a police
officer with the city of los angeles
approximately five and a half years
did you serve in any law enforcement
capacity prior to coming to the lapd
no
when you said approximately five and a
half years do you recall
approximately you started employment
with the lapd
approximately november of 2015.
did you attend the police academy prior
to november 2015 or did you attend it
after you became employed by the lapd
you're on november of 2015. we turned
into the academy in 2015 that november
that volume's a little loud
thank you
and how long were you with the academy
approximately six months
and when did you start
as a patrol officer with the lapd
uh six months after november
can you recall
your date when you started patrol i
don't recall the exact date no and that
would be may end of may of 2016.
right
and was the first training officer that
you worked with on patrol melissa
science
yes question when did you first have
body worn video assigned to you
i'm not sure of the exact date
approximately when
approximately three months into working
patrol
so maybe during the summer time
the summer of 2016
correct
when you started working with
melissa science as your training officer
did officer science have body video
not at the time i worked with her how
much training did you have on domestic
violence while you were at the academy
i don't recall the exact amount of time
approximately how much
20 hours approximately
okay
so just to make sure that i understand
if you have a few disjointed questions
and answers so it was your understanding
as of
may 2016
that if you
answered a call for domestic violence
and there was evidence of a crime even
if the victim did not want to press
charges
that you had to take a report is that
correct
if there's evidence of a crime yes so
so
your best recollection today
is that you
had been
on patrol as a probationary officer
somewhere between a week and three weeks
before answering the may 21 2016
domestic violence call at eastern
columbia building is that correct
correct
do you recall any of the other incidents
that you reported to
that evening
of may 21 2016.
no
at all any part of them
nope
so this was new for you working with
officer science is that correct
all right
and as the probationary officer
then you would defer to officer science
is that fair
right
and if you could just describe to me
what your understanding of officer
science role
was to you as your training officer in
may
2016. to
teach me and
guide me on how to become a
complete the duties of being a law
enforcement officer
officer hadden
under your understanding of the lappd
rules
in
2016
if
a victim of domestic violence said that
the altercation was only verbal would
you
would that require you to write a report
no
okay
now i'm going to ask you to take a look
at the first page of what has been
marked as deposition exhibit number one
number faction number three my apology
um
and this is an incident recall
do you what is your understanding of
what this document is officer hasn't
uh it's essentially what
is given to us on
our computer
and what do you mean is given to us on
our computer in our car
right so
what happens
so when we're assigned a radio call the
radio call comes to our computer and our
car
and this is what we see on our screen
but in a different format
now
how was this particular call
characterized
by the dispatch at least initially
initially it was dispatched as a
domestic radio phone
and what does
domestic radio call mean to you
that there's
some type of whether it's disagreement
all the way up to
a
violent crime that's occurred between
two people are in some type of
relationship or have some children in
common
so officer had this comes out into the
system
and it's accessible by all of the
lapd black and whites that are on patrol
that night correct
yes whoever is logged in and working
that night i could look up any
division's radio calls if i wanted to
and then it has next it has a ds
and then er after stat what does that
mean ds means dispatched
er means we're in route
so
at 8
46 and 37 seconds pm
your
vehicle was on route to 849 south
broadway correct
correct
you recall how far away you were
i do not recall
and then it says primary unit pd181-w3
what is that
that's my call assignment so the pd is
police department only one is my car
assignment w3 means i work watch three
okay
then we have at 20
57 which is 8 57 pm
that is a.s what does that mean
at scene like we're there
all right so so you arrived at the scene
at 8 57 p.m correct
right
what did you do then
we
walked to the location
do you recall
anything that you did before you went up
to the penthouse
uh we walked in and
met with security who showed us where
the elevator was
did you do anything else
[Music]
um but your best recollection is that
you went in you talked to security and
then you
went on an elevator is that right yes
do you recall what time you arrived at
the
apartment the penthouse no i don't know
all right then your next entry here is
21 22
so that would be 9 22 p.m and 57 seconds
yeah okay
net with victim
tech lock verified has been last
location
victim advised verbal do you see that
um that's what we write
when we
put the comments of the call of what
happened in the radio call that's what
we wrote
so do you recall whether that was you
that wrote that or officer science
um i don't recall the road all right
and and so you were back in your vehicle
by 9 22 is that correct
approximately yeah
well if you wrote this at 9 22
would it be fair to say you were back in
your vehicle writing this yes
okay
um
now did you take a report
uh we issued a business card
i asked did you take a report no
why not
because
the
victim didn't request report and during
our investigation didn't reveal that we
need to take a report
so
who decided to use the words victim
advised verbal
dispute
the
whoever created the comments of the call
used the word victim
whoever gave the comments of the call
gave use the word victim
so i don't know who that was
and i'm even more specifically asking
who chose the language advised verbal
dispute
is either my partner or i i don't recall
who
now
what is the significance of writing down
verbal dispute
we're writing what happened what we
believe has happened and what we
our investigation revealed
but
you were not
present at any time
when
ms heard discussed
whether there was any type of verbal
argument is that correct was i there yes
was i speaking to her no
was there any discussion
a verbal argument in your presence
in when you were up in the penthouse
investigating
you did not hear ms heard say that it
was only a verbal dispute correct
i did not
now
i asked you a little earlier if it's a
verbal dispute whether that triggers
having to write a report
and you indicated that it has not am i
accurately characterizing that
right
okay
now here in addition to the
victim-advised verbal dispute
says and refused
to give any further information you see
that
yes
question okay so the victim does not
want to press charges and
and advises that it's a verbal dispute
then that would not trigger you writing
a report is that your understanding of
lapd
all season procedures on domestic
violence at that time correct there are
other circumstances that were also
within this incident as well
what do you mean by that
during our investigation we had other
reasons to believe
that this was true
i'm sorry during your investigation you
had other reasons to believe what was
true
that it was a verbal dispute
and what
did you
have during your investigation that
created in your mind evidence that it
was only a verbal dispute
after discussing the investigation with
my partner at the city
the
misheard
refused any medical treatment and had no
visible injuries there was no sign of
struggle
and the victim or correction the witness
that was there that i spoke with
was uncooperative as well
anything else
at this time that's all
okay now
you recall
seeing that miss heard was in tears and
was crying and red-faced would you agree
correct from a distance
well
from a distance ms heard was in tears
crying and had a red face correct
correct why did you issue a business
it's part of our
policy we're supposed to issue a
business card
and
it shows that we are there and completed
an investigation
and
if
she would like us to come back we offer
that assistance that we can come back at
another time if she feels like she's
just come back
did you take any notes at all
no to what
no during the time that you were
investigating this call no
did you take any notes after you got
back down to your car about the call
no
did you take any pictures
no
did you record anything
no
would it be fair to say that on 5 21
2016 at 9 22 p.m
you and your training officer
science
considered this incident closed i said
yes that is correct at that time
we
pressed enter and that's all went off my
screen meaning it was completed
did you
ever have anything come up on your
screen again relating to this incident
that evening not that i recall
all right at the time that you closed
out this incident on your screen at 9 22
on 5 21 2016
did you know that this call
involved johnny depp
no
did you
at the time that you closed this out on
your screen
were you did you recognize amber heard
no i had no idea who she was
and is it fair to say
that you
considered these people to be
quote just citizens end of quote
that's correct
do you have any communications
at all with officer gatlin or his his
patrol partner
the night
of
may 21st 2016. no not the article
so the next thing we're gonna go to
is
the cad summary which is at page 12 of
exhibit number
three
and this is a cad summary report and it
also has the name dfar report at the top
and it's for 521 2016.
and says specifically
officers hadden and officer
signed
do you see that yes typically
when you would arrive for your shift
was there a period of time that you
would do things maybe at the uh at the
precinct or whatever before you get into
your vehicle and log on and go forward
yes
all right what typically would you do
back in 2016
i would
change put on my uniform
and then i would have a roll call
where we'd be given our assignments
and then we would stand in line and
check out our equipment
and check out our car
and then we have to go
put our equipment in the car
and then
wash the car
vacuum the car
gas the car
and then
go and find out if there's any radio
calls pending
okay and so
how long would it typically take for you
to do all those things from putting your
uniform on through the time you start
checking for radio calls
um
i'm not sure approximately an hour
how many people
how many police officers patrol officers
were part of that
that roll call
i don't know the exact number i would
say
approximately 30.
and when you said you had to stand in
line to check out your equipment was it
all 30 of those patrol officers that
would get in line and check out their
equipment yes and supervisors
okay
and
what equipment were you checking out
that night
a shotgun a less lethal shotgun
mics for our cameras inside the car
pouches for our mics
batteries for our radios
keys for the cars
hazer
um
i think that's about it right now
do you have a recollection of there
being cameras inside your car back on
may 21 2016.
yes i believe so now
you arrived at the penthouse
you saw that there was a female
holding and embracing
ms herb correct
i believe it was uh when i was leaving
the location when we were getting ready
to leave
okay
now
you believed that ms heard was
uncooperative because she was being
emotional
crying
was refusing
that she
was hurt and she didn't know initially
whether she wanted to file a report or
not and then she didn't want to file a
report correct
right
now
you said that officer science told you
later that ms heard called the number on
the business card
do you recall when officer signs told
you that ms heard called the number on
the card no i don't
recall
do you recall approximately how much
time you spent
at the penthouse
speaking with either the mail or with
miss heard or looking at the premises
that night
uh don't recall right now
you
recall roughly whether it was 15 minutes
a half hour hour
i don't i don't recall
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number 17. i'll just scroll down
so you can see that hold on
do you recognize the person in this
photo
well i believe that's this hurt
all right is this the same person you
saw on the night of may 21 2016
when you arrive sometime after 904 pm
and do you recall seeing the red marks
that are reflected on
this exhibit number 17 on ms third no i
was never this close to
be able to examine her face
you were never never close enough to
miss her to be able to examine her face
is that what you said right
okay
um
if you had seen
these this mark close enough to be able
to see it
would you have
believed you had an obligation to
prepare a report
no because i don't know what this is
from
right
would you agree it's a red mark on her
face
from what i saw was
red from her crying there was no red
marks from
any other thing it was consistent with
her crying
does this look like a red mark that's
from crying officer hadn't um
would
in reviewing this picture
does it appear that there's an injury
on
ms heard's face in this picture no
you would say that doesn't evidence an
injury
no
why not
because i don't see an injury
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition exhibit number 18
and uh
do you recognize this carpeting
no
officer what do you see in this picture
i see
stripes
with
some type of things on uh
to be a possible flooring
okay
do you have a recollection of seeing
stains on the flooring
um
outside of
this herd's
penthouse that night
of may 21st 2016.
at this point knockout
and when you say at this point now that
you can recall what do you mean by that
it's five years ago i don't remember
officer hadn't i'm going to show you
what zuma just had in exhibit number 19.
do you recognize the
business card
yes
and tell me what you can recall of that
um well that's my handwriting and those
are
our lapd business cards
all right the the next thing on there is
refuse report
do you see that
yes okay
was it your understanding that ms heard
did not want to press charges
uh she spoke with my partner and that's
what my partner advised me
okay were you ever in the room
when ms heard
either quote refused report or refused
to press charges
i believe we offered her one final
chance before we gave her the business
part if she needed medical treatment or
a report
and she declined at that time and that's
when we issued this business card
and what did you mean by report
um an official
investigative report
is that the victim's choice to write
whether you write an official
investigative report
yeah
a citizen can read ask for a report for
anything essentially with lapd
but
do you
have
an obligation
as an lapd patrol officer to get a
report
if you see injuries or property
if there's evidence of a crime yes
and when you say if there's evidence of
a crime would injuries and property
damage constitute evidence of a crime
if there's evidence of a crime again
okay
is there something
different about what you're saying than
what i'm asking
well i'm trying to understand when i say
if you see evidence of injuries and
property damage is that evidence of a
crime in your mind
yes if the person didn't commit do it
themselves i mean i i can damage my own
property in climate crime
okay
did you have any reason to believe that
amber heard
created any injuries to herself or to
the property at the time you were there
on
may 21st 2016. no it don't require
seeing
damaged property or
obtaining any injuries or having
invisible injuries that i saw
now it says advise can call at later
time
if changes mind
what if any discussion did you have with
officer signs about what that meant
well let that goes with what i said
earlier was
assistant can make a report about
anything at any time it's called
investigative report or just an incident
report
so if she wanted a report then she would
call us back and we'll take a report
but at that point you have already
written into your system that the victim
advised verbal dispute only correct
correct
and you did not write a report or take
pictures or
create any kind of
record did you have anything that
transpired there
uh just the business part
i'm going to ask you
officer had to take a look at what has
been marked as deposition exhibit number
24. do you recognize the person in this
picture
mister
well
do you recognize her as miss hurt
no no you had no idea what he was do you
recognize the person in this picture on
haddon exhibit number 24
as the person
who was the
the
subject of
your and officer signs
reporting to
the eastern columbia building that
evening
correct all right so let's go to uh
exhibit number 24
and do you
what do you see in this picture with
respect to whether there is any injury
depicted on misheard i see a uh female
white fair skin with uh
i'm sorry with a white
pink cheek and pink eyes
all right
do you
recognize that as a potential injury on
her face
knowing what our investigation revealed
no it's that pink's consistent with
brian
what do you mean by what your
investigation revealed
that it was a
verbal dispute
and she refused that she had any injury
and just so we're clear again
you were never
in the presence of misheard
when she at any time said it was only a
verbal dispute correct
now
would you as a police officer
investigating
if you saw this
what's depicted in this picture
would you believe that you need to
investigate further
uh yeah i would need additional
information
uh just because i see a female with pink
cheeks and pink eyes doesn't mean that
something happened
they should be sad and crying that their
dog died
did you
engage in any further investigation no
the only investigation i did was part of
speaking my partner and
then uh speaking with the witness
with the witness the next door neighbor
and what did you discuss with the
witness the next door neighbor
i tried to obtain information of what
occurred
what did you ask
uh who what when where why
and what did he say
uh i don't remember his exact words but
he wasn't
very coming with the information
i have very vague vague information as
far as
what he was telling me
what do you specifically recall
the witness telling you i don't recall
you don't recall at all i don't recall
specific words or sentences
do you recall the witness
taking you around and showing you
property damage in the penthouse
no i recall my part and i doing a
protective sweep
and that's it
you don't recall josh drew being with
you and taking you through
i don't recall i don't recall someone
else was with us or not
do you recall one way or the other
uh
i don't recall
all right now you have a recollection of
you and and officer science
going through the entire penthouse is
that correct we did a protective sweep
of
the location that she was on
and tell me what you mean by protective
suite we walk through
the general housing area that she is at
to make sure that
there's no one else in it that shouldn't
be there or there's
no
you know no no one hurt
do you recall how many rooms you went
through no no i don't know
let me ask you if the officer had to
take a look at number 25 you recognize
this as misheard
yes
right and do you
see any injuries depicted on this
picture
no
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as exhibit number 26. do you
recognize this as ms heard yes
okay do you see any injuries
in this picture
no
i'm going to ask you the same question
uh exhibit number 27 do you recognize
this as miss heard yes
and do you see any injuries
in this picture on this road no
you can ask the same questions officer
hadden
uh i'm going to ask you to look at had
an exhibit number 28 do you recognize
this as miss her
yes
and do you see any injuries depicted on
ms heard's face in this picture no
i'll show you exhibit number 29 do you
recognize this as ms word yes
do you see any injuries on this heard in
this picture
no
now you indicated that you and officer
signs uh
went through the
apartment correct
correct we did a protective sweep
detective suite and in doing the
protective sweep you did go in the room
correct
uh well i mean i don't know exactly
where we went but we walked around
what she claimed was her
living quarter
would you agree that if ms heard
displayed injuries at the time that you
reported to her residents after the
domestic violence call that you would
have had an obligation to prepare a
report
if there was uh injuries or complaining
pain yes
i'm sorry injuries or what complaint
opinion would you agree that uh if ms
heard displayed injuries that you
perceive to be injuries at the time you
reported to ms heard's residence after
the domestic violence call on may 21st
2016 you had an obligation to re to
prepare a report
if i perceive them to be injuries then
yes
would you agree that if there was
property damage present
at the time you reported to miss herd's
residence after the domestic violence
calls you had an obligation to prepare a
report
no because if she's living there that's
her property
and she's being uncooperative and
doesn't say that
someone else did it
or
anyone else did it then
i have no other information to go off of
she could have broken it herself
sir
[Music]
did you
provide any
pamphlets to ms hearn new or officer
signs relating to domestic violence
i personally did not
do you know whether officer science did
i don't know
and ladies and gentlemen at this point
counsel for mr depp takes over the
question
did you see miss hurt's face on the
evening of may 21 2016. yes
on how many occasions did you see her
face
i believe too
and the first time
you saw
her face
uh how close to her were you
uh i don't recall exactly i think it was
approximately 10 feet
did you perceive any uh did you have any
um
problems with your eyesight at that time
did you have 20 20 vision as of may 21
2016
uh no i wear contacts though so i can't
see perfectly fine
were you wearing your contacts that
evening yes did you have any trouble uh
seeing the contours of her face the
first time you saw her that evening
did you perceive any signs of injury on
her face or anywhere else on her body
that was visible to you no
for how long a period did you
view her face the first time you saw her
that night
a few seconds not very long
and
how much later was the second time you
saw miss heard
right before we left
and
how close
to her were you when you observed her
face approximately 10 feet
did you have a clear view of her face
yes
did you still have your contacts in at
the time
yes
was there sufficient light that enabled
you to actually see her face i believe
so i i believe it was uh the light was a
little dimmer but it was still lit
did you perceive
any signs of injury to her face on that
second occasion no
did you see
any swelling of any kind on her face
either do it during the first
time you saw her or the second time you
saw her that night
no
did you see any marks on her face either
the first time you observed her that
night or the second time you observed
her just the redness for which was
consistent with her crying
did you did you see
any time that night any indication of
any bruising on her face
no
did you see at any time that evening any
any indication
or any sign whatsoever of any injury to
her face
no
and going to
your
was it the security what was the term
you used the security sweep is that
correct
the protective sweep protective sweep
during your protective sweep
was your access bar to any part of the
pet house my access what sorry
uh did you have
free access uh to to the penthouse
the the witness that was there he kind
of i believe he guided us kind of
through
the place
i don't know
you know wherever he guided us through
did you see any broken glass anywhere in
the penthouse where you did the
protective sweep
not that i remember
were you looking for any
signs of a disturbance
yes
why were you looking for signs of a
possible disturbance
um signs of
any evidence that a crime has occurred
is that part of is that standard
procedure a police procedure
yes and why
do you look for potential signs of of
vandalism or disturbance to property in
the course of a domestic violence
violence allegation or possibility
um
just because that tends to happen when
uh
some type of domestic
altercation occurs between two people
did you see any sign of any kind of
property damage or vandalism that
evening
not that i recall
did you see any signs of spilled wine
on the floor
not that i recall
if they were visible or uh comply to
pain do you recall
some questioning from ms hurd's counsel
ms brettahoft
about
a man who led you through the penthouses
on the evening of may 21 2016. yes
did you um
describe him as uncooperative
yes let me ask another question was he
cooperative
with your inquiries that evening
no
what do you mean by that
i attempted to gather information of
who the husband was um and what occurred
and um where he possibly went
so we could interview kind of all the
different parties
and uh
he he wouldn't wouldn't give me a name
of who the husband was
and
how long did you interact with that
person who who in fact is josh drew
i
i'd say approximately five to ten
minutes
did he report to you in words or
substance
that any domestic violence had occurred
i don't recall any exact verbiage he
said
did he report to you in words or
substance
any vandalism
no not that i recall
on the evening that uh you and your
partner got a call uh to the penthouse
on may 21 2016
were you and your partner in a
particular hurry to close out
this incident no
you were you willing to to stay as long
as was necessary to to resolve the
matter
yes
would you generally take notes for a
verbal dispute only when when we
disciple the call and we get rid of the
call we leave our comments of what
occurred and what we did in that call
would you generally write a report
for a verbal dispute only
no unless it's uh
at the request of one of the parties
when you were typing in your computer to
add text to a call
is it common to refer to the focus
individual in the call as a victim
whether she whether a crime has been
committed or not yes because that's how
the
fall was broadcasted and created
ladies and gentlemen at this point
counsel for
miss heard
completes the questioning
now there was another woman that was
present
as well correct that name
um
i believe so yes
do you remember testifying earlier that
at the end she was holding and embracing
ms heard yeah i believe she's on sitting
on the couch with her when we left
did you interview that woman
no she was with uh
misheard when uh my partner was speaking
with her i believe she i never spoke to
her
okay because did you ever attempt to
interview that woman that was on the
couch who was embracing this vote no
because i was speaking with the
gentleman outside
do you know whether officer science ever
attempted to interview that woman who
was sitting on the couch
i'm unaware
okay
now let's go back to
the description that you gave and you
responded again to it with mr chu
that
she had she was crying
and had a red face and you said the
redness was consistent with crying do
you recall that
yes
okay why was she crying i don't know
that's a great question i don't know why
she was crying
did you ask her
i personally did not because my partner
interviewed her
then when you downloaded with your
partner later did you ask for officer
science why amber heard was crying
no my partner never advised me she spoke
with her
while i was speaking with the gentleman
do you recall that you testified that
there was another woman who was
embracing this heard on the sofa at the
end of your visit
yes
do you
recall asking why she was bracing and
holding ms heard why
did you not ask either the other woman
or ms heard why the woman was embracing
and holding this herd
well i did not is because we were
trained in the academy to separate the
parties
and to try and attempt to build a
rapport with the individual you're
speaking with
therefore it was two females and my
partner was female so therefore my
partner spoke with the females
would it be fair to say you deferred to
officer signs to conduct any type of
investigation with both ms heard and the
other woman who was embracing her
i know my partner spoke with
miss heard i am unaware i cannot testify
if she spoke with the other
female
when you said you learned at the academy
to divide up the parties was it your
understanding that parties meant the
victim and the suspect all parties
do you know whether anyone made an
attempt to divide up the woman from ms
heard the woman that was embracing her
i'm unaware
okay
now
the redness that you said was on miss
herb's face
uh when she was
crying and emotional
could it also have been consistent with
injury i do not think so i had perceived
it as redness from crying
did you consider
whether the redness on the face
might
be from something in addition to crying
no i did not
and you had never met ms heard before
correct never never
and would it be fair to say that you
don't know what ms heard uh
what her characteristics are for
swelling bruising
redness correct
correct
i'm going to ask you officer hadden to
look at what has been marked as
uh had an exhibit number eight and it's
from the office of the chief of police
and it's
dated november
2014
and the subject is domestic violence
supplemental report form
15.40.02 revised do you see that
i do
this was provided to us by the lapd in
response to our document requests
did you have an understanding
that there was a domestic violence
supplemental report form that was in
place as of now as of may 21st 2016.
yes
i'm going to show you what is exhibit
number nine
and
this is called domestic violence
supplemental report
and it is something is it your
understanding that the police officer
fills this out
yes so we fill that up
okay
do you recall whether you had filled out
this supplemental report at any time
prior to may 21st 2016.
i don't worry paul now if we look at the
first column on the domestic violence
supplemental report it has a column that
says victim
and then there are a number of
descriptive words underneath with boxes
do you see that i do
all right now the first one is shaking
what if any observations did you make of
ms heard shaking
no i don't know
all right what if any uh observations
did you make about misheard being
the unresponsive time i
dealt with her
uh yeah she was unresponsive crying
i'm sorry i didn't catch the first part
she was
unresponsive and crying did you say
yes
okay
and i guess you've answered the third
one here that she was crying correct
yes
all right and what if any observations
did you make whether amber heard was
scared
i didn't
you didn't what i did not observe
i'm sorry
are you finished with that answer it
sounded like it was a half i just want
to make sure you yeah i did not observe
her being fearful
okay but ms heard did not want to
file a report correct
correct you did not want to
press charges correct all right
and she did not want to tell you the
name of her husband correct i don't know
because i didn't talk to her
well do you recall
testifying earlier
that ms heard was uncooperative
yes she was uncooperative with my
partner
all right and do you recall testifying
that miss heard was uncooperative
because she was emotional she was crying
she wasn't sure whether she wanted to
file a report or not and she was not
then she said she did not want to
yes that's uh what she had spoke with my
partner about
do you know why
ms heard did not want to file a report i
did not want to press charges no i did
not
officer head and i'm going to show you
what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number 10
and
i'm going to
have you looked at it it starts out with
field notebook divider domestic violence
laws lapd form 18.3 0.02
and it has the date this is
date of january 31 2010 at the bottom
with the uh
with the footnote i'm going to just
direct your attention here to case
preparation and this is relating to
domestic violence laws
case preparation says note the
complainant's emotional and physical
condition you see that
yes
and then ensure all evidence is gathered
and preserved eg bloody closing clothing
damaged bones damaged property
you see that
yes okay did you or officer
signs
provide any kind of notes relating to
miss herd's emotional and physical
condition on may 21 2016
no did you or officer science ensure all
the evidence was gathered and preserved
including a damaged property i said no
and all these things would have been
documented if there was a report
all right let's go to the next bullet
point says ensure photographs are taken
of injuries
or
lack of injury
to complainant
and accused
both the day of and
after
did you take any photographs to show a
lack of injury
no
did you take any photos to show a lack
of damage
no
all right
and then this next one is ensure
photographs are taken of the scene and
damaged property etc
so i've already asked you that one so
let's go to the next one
canvas location and interview all
witnesses
including children neighbors law
enforcement
did you do that in this instance
yes
where did you interview
i spoke with the gentleman
all right anyone else
no that's it
now there were two
females present in addition to ms hurd
were there nine
uh yes uh
including her i do there's two
you don't recall the third woman there
no i don't recall a third one being
there
all right did you ask if there was
anybody else that was present who had
witnessed any aspect of
this
i don't recall exactly but
let's go to
exhibit number 11.
so what did you determine this call was
after your investigation
a dispute
a verbal dispute
it's not against the law to argue i
argue in my life
so you decided that there was only a
verbal dispute therefore it didn't
constitute domestic violence from the
information or lack of information i was
able to receive from the witness and the
information my partner gathered yes is
it your understanding that
a police officer
can be
brought up on charges of misconduct
if they engage in
neglect of duty
uh yes
right is it also your understanding that
a police officer can be brought
up on misconduct charges at the lapd if
they violate department policies rules
or procedures
yes
and is it your understanding that a
police officer can be brought up on
charges of misconduct if they engage in
conduct which may tend to reflect
unfavorably upon the employee or the
department
yes
all right
thank you your next witnesses by
deposition also i assume you need a few
minutes to switch that out are you ready
to
we're ready
oh i think that's that's right okay well
we go ahead and it's early but let's go
ahead and take a morning recess for 15
minutes so we can take care of that and
get it set up with the next deposition
okay so don't talk to anybody don't do
any outside research all right
so
okay who's the next which deposition is
next officer william gatlin your honor
officer gatlin
okay we did the reactions that we
discussed and i don't know
i haven't seen it yet so i want to go
ahead and take the 15 minutes and when i
come back we can we can figure it out
and how long is this deposition
i believe it's around 35 minutes your
honor okay so we'll be able to start the
next one right now we should be able to
go ahead and get the exhibits for the
next one after that as well and i'll
come back at 11 20 and we can do both of
them okay
all right thank you
which evidence do we have
okay
all right are we ready for the jury then
yes okay yes your honor
all right thank you for your next
witness
okay
officer gatlin could you spell the last
name for me in the court quarter
g a
t
l i n okay thank you
and business address for director
william gatlin
business address 251 east 6th street in
los angeles california
90014
how long have you been an officer with
the lapd
uh eight years
and what is your rank
uh police officer two now your partner
on may 21 2016 was officer dino is that
correct
yes
you were wearing your body cam
on 21 2016 yes
when were you first assigned body
cameras
um
sometime in 2015
i think
you know i don't remember
gatlin i'm going to show you what has
been marked as
defendant's exhibit number six
and i'm going to go ahead and go down to
the second page
and this is the incident recall
for
the two for you and
officer deaner
for
may 21 2016
in connection with the call at the
eastern columbia building 849 south
broadway
now officer deaner indicated that he
believed that he was driving that night
is that your recollection as well
uh yes when officer deaner is driving
what does that mean you're doing
uh it means i handle uh the computer
based on the incident recall
when did you arrive at the scene u.n
officer demon we arrived at scene it
looks like at 22 24.
and that is
10 24
correct so when you arrived do you
recall whether there were any other
police
officers that were on the scene
i do not believe there was
do you recall whether there was any
press on the scene
i do not believe there was
do you recall whether there was any type
of public gathering involved
no
was it relatively quiet
uh from my recollection yes
uh did you see very many people in the
lobby when you came through
not that i remember
okay um
and then tell me what you recall
of this incident once you got there and
you were shown to the elevator
um i remember we went up the elevator
um
exited the elevator
walk down the hallway until he found the
unit number
uh knocked on the door a mail answered
the door
and
at that point
i mean at that point i i really didn't
know
whether this guy is potentially the
suspect if this guy is involved in the
altercation or who this guy was
so we kind of talked to him for a second
and he advised us that the police had
already been there he had a business
card from them
and we told him that we
still needed to step inside to check on
the subject or potential victim just to
make sure that
she's okay and that this is indeed
related to the previous incident and not
a new incident where the suspect had uh
potentially
returned and caused there's another new
issue at hand
so do you recall that you already knew
that this had this place had their that
another officer had had uh answered the
caller other officers had answered the
call before you got there yes
i already knew there was a previous
caller and how did you know that
um
just kind of keeping track when you're
on the computer you kind of are able to
keep track of the calls throughout the
night and
where they're at and what's going on
and did you know that officer science
and and hadn't had been the ones who had
answered the call earlier
um
i i believe so
okay
um
did you speak with officer science or
officer hadden before you went to
the eastern columbia building
no
i'm going to take you down to
the same exhibit
the page that's uh
bait stamp numbered lapd 11.
and i'm going to ask you this is a
t-o-m-s-g data log do you recognize this
document i've never seen this before
i've never seen one of these documents
before
all right do you have a recollection
of receiving an administrative message
at 22 22 30 which would be 10 22 30. uh
saying
uh incident four seven five six is the
same incident as yours one a one handled
earlier doubt she called back probably
just delayed response
uh i did not recall i do not recall
getting that message right below it
at 22 23 22 which is 10 23 and change um
it shows
that your unit responded with rob in
other words roger
to that message do you see that yes
would that have been you that did that
or would that have been officer deena
uh probably me
okay and is that because you weren't
driving an officer dean or was yes
okay so does this refresh your
recollection
of what had been communicated to you and
why you knew that someone had already
answered this call earlier uh
yes
are you familiar with the term cycle of
violence
yes
well typically do you make arrests on
domestic abuse
calls um
you know sometimes we do and sometimes
the other party is no longer at scene
and we would just take a report
okay are there times where they just
refuse to cooperate and you just left
um
yeah but yeah there are terms like that
we were going to say but what i guess
like the totality of the circumstance
based on
just because someone's uncooperative
doesn't automatically mean that we'll
just leave you know if we're you know
observe some kind of injuries or if
there's a third party witness that's
cooperative
that could lean in where even if the
victim's uncooperative that would still
take some sort of action now i'm going
to ask you to turn to
number page 13 here
and this is the
cad summary report what if any uh
involvement did you have in this
um so
uh i would be the one that kind of
closes out the incidents on the computer
so the
writings over to the right of the screen
would be
the how i would what i would type into
the computer to close out the call
and so you would have typed in related
to previous incident verbal argument
only checked residence yes
who told you that it was a verbal
argument only
based on
uh the knowledge i had of the previous
call i'm able to see
[Music]
potentially how they closed out the call
and i could have seen it from there
so you could have gotten this from a1a
1a1 yeah their report officer science
and officer hadn't and then just
repeated it here
uh yes
do you have any recollection of anyone
in the apartment
up in penthouse 3
saying that there had been a verbal
argument only
um not to my recollection
well let me just jump back to the events
of may 21 for a moment were you aware
that that was the apartment of johnny
depp and amber heard no
when did you first become aware of that
i don't remember
talking months days hours it was a
couple days
and do you remember how you learned of
it
no i don't
and did you know who johnny depp was at
that time uh yeah
and were you a fan of johnny depp's as
of may 21 2016.
um
i guess i've liked a couple of his
movies
i don't know
i'm not like rushing out to go see him
or anything i don't know
are you a fan of johnny depp's today
i can remember the last movie i saw of
his
did you know who amber heard was as of
may 21 2016
i was aware that there was an actress by
the name of amber heard but i'm not was
not totally familiar with her or any of
her
any of her work
when you saw
the name amber heard
on the
incident he
recalls
did it register with you that she was an
actress
no
did you recognize amber heard when you
came to the apartment on may 21 2016. no
how close did you come to amber heard
while you were in the apartment
um
i'd have to say probably between 10 and
15 feet
and what was the lighting like where
amber horde was sitting
it's pretty uh dim
did you ask to see amber heard's face in
the light
no
did you ask and referred whether she had
any injuries
no
did you interview any of the persons
present about what had taken place
earlier that night no
why not
because i was aware that there's a
previous call regarding the incident and
the mail to answer the door
uh kind of made it clear to us that
this is still
left over from that same incident and a
new incident had not occurred
so
i didn't feel the need to at that time
did you go through and search the entire
apartment including bedrooms offices and
other areas no
again why not
uh it's the same as i explained earlier
and they were all adamant that
her husband was no longer at scene
did you go into any of the other
adjoining apartments no
you asked where the husband was why did
you ask for the husband
uh because in the comments of the call
it stated the
husband and wife were arguing
and and it was also a domestic violence
uh yeah it's a domestic violence call
and it wouldn't be uncommon for
you know the male to answer the door to
tell us that he's not the husband and
later it turns out that he is so you
know we kind of have to talk to
the other party involved to make sure
that that's not
the mail that's involved in the argument
did any of the four people that were in
the apartment
identify
johnny depp as that mail
no
was there any effort by any of the
people in that apartment to get you to
press charges or investigate further
no
would you say the people were reluctant
to even have you come into the apartment
it felt that way
and what happened what occurred that
made it feel like that to you that they
didn't want to be they didn't want you
in the apartment um just the uh
the way that the uh male was acting they
answered the door he kind of just said
oh let me just go grab the business card
from the previous call
and then even so when we had went inside
uh it didn't seem like anybody was
particularly eager to talk to us
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
exhibit one defendant's exhibit one
and this is the daily mail mail online
july 3rd 2020 and i'm going to go down
to
the 10th page
what if any evidence
did you
observe when you went to the penthouse
on may 21 2016 that amber heard and her
friends
were attempting to concoct an abuse hoax
to set up johnny depp to be accused of
domestic violence
none that i can recall
what if any evidence did you see
uh amber and her friends spilling wine
and roughing the place up none
and what if any evidence did you see
that amber and her friends
were
had concocted and gotten their story
straight and were relaying them to you
when you arrived
none
did amber or her friends at any time
while you were at the apartment on may
21 2016
claim
that johnny depp had committed domestic
violence of amber not to me they didn't
did you see them do that to officer
deaner
no
what if any
efforts did amber heard
make to come over and to show you any
evidence of injuries
and what if any effort did amber heard
or her friends make to try to show you
any type of property damage
none
and what if any evidence do you have
that amber or her friends
may place a second call to 9-1-1 i don't
have any evidence that it was one of her
friends i just know that there is a
second call place
well actually if i can recall i think
it said that uh her friend was on the
phone with her and her arguing with her
husband
who said that i believe that's what the
incident recall said did you ever
provide a sworn deposition
uh saying that you sign her evidence of
a crime at the penthouse before today
no
are you aware of whether officer dean
provided a sworn deposition saying he
found no evidence he has not
uh now this uh
call came in at 20 30 which is
approximately 8 30
uh regular
p.m right yes
okay
um and then a little bit further down
just seven minutes later
comes a duplicate call
that appears to come from the new york
police department
roughly seven minutes of each other
correct yes did you see that when you
were looking back and trying to look at
the history
uh i believe i saw all of this
did you see in any of the incident
recalls or any of the documentation that
you reviewed that
there the officers officer science
manhattan reported to the scene
left the scene closed out and then
another call was made to come to 849
south broadway
um
yes
what did you see
the second call created was the one that
we had received
and it says
this is 2209 which would be 1009 right
roughly yes it says teletype from nypdik
female stated she was on the phone with
her friend she began screaming at her
husband
subject amber heard husband johnny kurd
male 53 years old 5 511 nfd nfl do you
see that yes
okay
but that's new york police department
and back here
it says new york police department
correct
correct
okay
but
after you communicated
down here
and the administrative
text messages and i'm now on lapd 11.
this is 2222
you now know it's the same incident as
yours and 1a1 handled earlier
doubt she called back probably just
delayed response correct yeah this is
just a message from another unit so i
mean
just because they're telling they're
basically just sending a message that
it's related
you know it it doesn't mean that
it's exactly the same call
by the time you showed up at the door
penthouse 3
at the eastern columbia building
you already knew
that officer science had handled this
call and you were just double checking
to make sure that the perpetrator wasn't
there and that everybody was okay
correct i was aware that officer science
had handled a call at that location
earlier
but it doesn't mean that i
have to that i treat it as if it's
handled already we still have to
get there and speak to them and make
that determination
that it's not a completely new incident
okay
and you did that right yes
and you put in the system
for this call
21 20 20 46 to 2122
met with vic
check location verified husband left
location victim advised verbal dispute
and refused to give any further
information actually that was happening
signs right that wasn't me i didn't put
that in
then what you put in that was why i
couldn't find you
you put in
2217 and i'm sure you weren't there
until 301 but we talked about some dates
about that you put in related to
previous incident verbal argument only
checked resonance correct
yes
okay and
your putting verbal argument only was
based on what you could review with
science and having correct
uh yes i'm going to show you what has
been marked as defendant's exhibit
number two
uh and it's a
picture it's a portion of the video clip
from the ecb building
and it has 521 2016 and the time is
22.28 14.
do you recognize the person in this
picture yes and who who is in this
picture officer deaner i'm going to ask
you to take a look at defendants exhibit
number three
and that's
reflecting a video clip again
and it's david 5 21 2016 and says 22 28
15.
um do you recognize the person in this
yeah that's me and officer diner
i'm going to uh show you now the video
cam footage i've got
coffee's hot
burning
we're stepping on to the penthouse
um
[Music]
[Music]
three
hello
officers how are you doing i'm doing all
right um
you guys have somebody come out here
earlier
okay
yeah we got another call i don't know if
it's related to the same call from
earlier or if somebody called again
probably but we just see the check
someone in new york or something yes she
probably call it twice okay yeah is uh
you just talk to your wife and make sure
it's not so much
oh okay
different conversation
yeah well whoever it is you know step
out you just gotta check on make sure
they're all good i'll go get the
business card from the cops
yeah i don't know just because we got
another call and we came again we still
got to make sure
please back up
can we just we'll just come in and just
say we just need to make sure everybody
in here is okay
yeah
i don't know if she calls wise or
whoever called but we just got another
notification
so
we just knew they'd come in and make
sure that everybody's okay
and they're all good nobody else was in
here no
the other officer came by and checked
the department and the other apartment
johnny
is definitely not here
a good night
so this one is defendant's exhibit
number four
[Music]
three
before we go further can you to uh show
you now the you're putting virgin says
22-28-15
um do you recognize the person in this
yeah that's me and officer dinner
i'm going to uh show you now the video
cam footage i've got the two
uh from yours and from officer
deaner so i'm going to go through and
show those to you
so this one is defendant's exhibit
number four
coffee's hot
burning
word round penthouse 3.
to the penthouse
is
[Music]
[Applause]
before we go further can you tell
whether this one is your video cam
footage or it is officer demons
uh this appears to be officer deaners
and so that's you over here yes
can you tell whether it's you or officer
dana that's saying officer signs
um i cannot tell okay how did you know
that it was officer signs who'd been
there uh because i was aware which unit
had responded to the call there and i
knew that she was working that
i unit know if it's related to the same
call from earlier or if somebody called
again
probably we just need to check
someone in new york or something yeah
she could probably call it twice okay
yeah
you just talk to
that josh drew
was discouraging you from even coming
into the apartment
or seeing number heard
uh yes
yeah
i don't know if she called twice
or whoever called but we just got
another notification
so
we just need to come in to make
all right officer gatlin can you tell
which one of these people is doing
attacking of these three girls women
um
i can't tell first her but it appears to
me it's the
girl in the middle
that's
the one that's leaning forward with the
white shirt
do you know which one of these is amber
herb
um from this view i can't tell
all right do you know what color care
the person that's the most forward
that's in the middle it has
uh i can't tell from this
okay can you tell what color hair the
woman
the furthest light is it's in front
i can't tell it looks like her head is
in a shadow
okay can you tell what color hair the
person that's uh
middle but in the back
no same everything looks like they're
the tops of their heads are in shadows
all right and you believe that the one
to the left is amber heard
um
no i
i believe that that's the one that's
doing most of the talking
[Music]
and the other reporting
did you see anybody acknowledge that
they identify themselves as
uh it looks like it was the girl sitting
furthest away from me prefer this away
from the camera
okay and how would you describe the
lighting in there
uh pretty
dim and uh dark you said earlier you
thought you were 10 to 15 feet away how
much would you estimate now that you are
looking at this on body cam how far away
are you from the three women
i would still say it's in that range did
you get a clear look at any of these
three women
um
i can't remember and did you ask
to have any of them come out into the
lighting so that you could take a better
look at them to see if potentially they
might have injuries
no
what perception did you have
about the level of cooperation of these
four individuals with your answer in
this call
a pretty
low level of cooperation
now can we uh
bring up uh exhibit number five
it's the other video i just want to run
through both of them because there's a
little bit of different angle in the two
hello
penthouse three
so
[Laughter]
so
so
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
or
okay
so
all right cool
everything's all good then
all right
[Laughter]
so
now showing you that defendant's exhibit
number five
and let me just stop here for a minute
does this appear to be
the video cam from your video cam uh yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
so
okay
[Laughter]
it must have been like
so i'm just stopping here again um
on these three women uh you had
indicated before the woman that's
leaning forward here that she's in the
middle is that correct uh it appears
that way and you think she's the one who
did most of the talking correct uh yeah
right now she was the one talking
okay and you believe that amber is the
one in the back behind her
yes
are you able to see the right side of
amber's face
from this camera view it looks like
she's kind of facing uh straight towards
me
so i would have been able to see the
right side of her face from there
would you have been able to see it
clearly
uh due to the low lighting probably not
very clearly
while we're still there can you tell how
much hair amber has covering the right
side of her face to your pictures
uh no it
looks like uh
from this camera view
most of the time like half of her head
is blocked from the woman in front of
her
can you tell whether she's wearing any
makeup
no
anything about good then
all right
do you recall looking for any injuries
in the faces of the three women
um no
[Laughter]
now uh officer gatlin do you recall
seeing two dogs in the house
yes
they were running around pretty freely
yes
and when you say that
would you be able to sit in here today
say that the person in these three
photos defendants seven eight and nine
is the same person that was sitting on
that sofa in the back are you able to
draw that connection
um
no i don't recall
do you
do you disagree with my description of
what's in this picture no i was stating
that i didn't observe that when i was
inside the apartment are you
able to testify
whether amber heard was the victim of
domestic violence by mr depp on may 21
2016.
uh based on our investigation it
appeared as if she was not
your investigation of what
based on her refusing to give
any statement on what had occurred
and at the time
we did not observe any
any visible or verifiable injuries
to her
anything else
not that i can recall
right so did you interview any of the
three other individuals in the apartment
no
did you ask any of the individuals to
give you a statement about what
transpired
i believe the female that was sitting in
the middle of the three
uh told us that everything was fine and
that the other officers had already
uh
conducted an investigation on the
incident prior to our arrival
did you ask
that individual to give you a statement
outside of that no
did you take that individual
aside and try to interview her without
the others present no
why not
uh as i just stated uh
everybody there had
told us that the officers who had
responded a couple hours before us had
conducted the investigation
and this is uh
our call is still stemming from that
incident
and there's been there have been no
change in the circumstance since then
do you know whether officer science and
officer hadden took any of the
individuals aside and interviewed them
no
did you at any point
ask amber heard to come forward and
examine her in the light to see if she
had any injuries
no
did you take a flashlight just to see if
she had any visible injuries to her face
or her body
no
did you ask him or her if she had any
injuries no
i'm asking whether you're in a position
as a police officer
to testify under oath
that johnny depp did not commit any
abuse of amber heard on may 21 2016. i
don't believe i'm in the position to
testify whether he did or did not
because i was not there when the
incident potentially occurred
okay
and you didn't conduct your own
independent investigation correct
outside of the female telling us that
everything was fine and uh the email
answered the door
that uh told us that the other officers
had already came and talked to everybody
and uh
she told us they checked the both the
two apartments
so
i felt at that time sufficient that
as i stated there's uh no change in the
circumstance from the previous call
so we did not go further into
investigation
and that's the extent of your
investigation correct correct did you do
that
that night on may 21 2016. did you do
anything
other than what
we have looked at on the video camera in
connection with investigating whether
johnny depp committed domestic problem
for bamboo hurt on may 21 2016.
no
do you know
whether johnny depp committed domestic
violence of amber heard on may 21 2016.
no
sorry your next witness
alejandro romero
alejandro romero
and if i might your honor um this is
another one that begins with questioning
by counsel for ms heard and later on
switches on to questioning by counsel
for mr depp
okay thank you
romero will you please state your name
and address for the record
my name i'm sorry my name is alejandro
romero
i go by alex
what is your current occupation
i'll work on the front desk of the
eastern columbia building
and is that for the action property
management company
that's correct
how long have you been employed at the
eastern columbia building
approximately 13 years
and could you please describe what kind
of work you do for the eastern
[Music]
foreign control and i deal with a lot of
residents regarding their packages
and food deliveries
and have you done that pretty much the
whole 10 years
that's correct
i'm going to take you back to 2015 and
2016 for a moment
how many people how many people would
you say
would go through the building on any
particular day in that time
and
i cannot say a number
because uh there's there's 147 units in
the building
and there's
uh
there are
friends
uh
actually we used to send delivery people
up
we don't sell it anymore because of the
kobe uh but i cannot tell you a number
there's
thousands of people probably have you
ever met johnny depp
i saw him a couple of times
do you remember what mr depp was wearing
on any of those equations
nope
do you remember what you read
nope
do you
remember
what headgear he was wearing because he
was wearing a scarf or a hat
[Music]
no
do you remember whether mr depp was
wearing any makeup or eyeliner
no
you couldn't tell me one way or the
other right
no
um do you know whether mr depp
has had ever been physically violent
with amber heard and by this i mean
hitting punching throwing objects at her
kicking her head butting her you know
one way or the other whether mr depp
ever did that to his heart
nope
do you ever
seen mr depp
uh slam things around or
be angry
no i have never seen him like that
i'm going to ask you some questions now
about amber fern
when did you first meet amber burke
um
i believe
she was bashing on the lobby i met at
the front desk
i got interact more with her sister with
me i believe her that's her name
and uh
her good friend uh raquel rocky
and uh but amber i only see him like
once in a while when she was uh
sometimes used to get packages
do you recall whether ms heard became a
resident
sometime around march 2016
[Music]
don't remember did you tell me one way
or the other
i just can't remember like i said it's
been so long i just don't remember and
like i know you guys sent me the papers
to review and i'm gonna be honest i
don't didn't want to review him because
it's been so long it's like
i
just don't want to deal with this
anymore
yes i went through the witness statement
and it's everything that is written
there that's what i said
that was correct it was that was
accurate
okay
so during the time between 2015 and
2016 how many times would you say total
that you interacted with them
for a whole year i i don't i could give
you a number because it could be like
probably i'll see you i'm probably
somewhere
three times in one day probably i'll say
like five times so probably i will never
see him for a whole week so i don't have
like there's not never been a routine
okay
how would you describe amber heard's
interactions with you were they friendly
did she smile at you would she talk with
you
she was really friendly
she would always smile
and but she we never had like a
like a uh interaction with uh
as
a really close relationship like uh like
i do with some of the other residents
she never told me any girl her problem
she never stopped by talk about her
personal life she never did that
they're asking you about
a date that you recall seeing amber
heard
on may 25th 2016. do you see that
yes i do
you said probably i just can't remember
the days i've got a really bad memory
for dates did you see that
yep
mr romero would you at any time be able
to remember
what type of clothing amber heard was
wearing
from one of her
events
nope i don't remember um
would you remember on any daily basis uh
what type of hairstyle she was there
no
would you remember on any type of basis
uh
what type of uh
bag she was amber heard was carrying
no
would you be able to say uh whether she
amber heard was dressed up or casual on
any given day
no
would you be able to
say
whether she was what type of makeup
amber bird was wearing on any given day
no
would you be able to say for example
whether amber heard had on concealer or
foundation
on any given day
no
would you be able to say whether amber
heard had on blush
or powder on any given day
no would you be able to say whether
amber heard had a mascara or eyeliner on
any given day
no
how about eyebrow pencil or lip pencil
no
do you have any memorable memories
of
amber heard
uh
wearing a particular type of makeup with
a type of outfit
no
if you were asked
uh to describe
uh any characteristics of amber or heard
from two days earlier without knowing
you were going to be asked would you be
able to testify to any of those what she
was wearing what her makeup was what her
hairstyle was
no i probably won't remember
when is the first time
that you recall
anyone saying anything to you
about the police being called
at the ec building
because of the domestic dispute between
mr depp and amber
well i have to answer your question
whatever happened it happened on a
saturday i don't work saturday when i
got there on monday
they asked me oh you heard what happened
and say no what happened
so that's how i find out
then i went to i went to the cameras and
see what was what was going on then as
soon as i saw johnny depp on the camera
on the elevator just walking back and
forward on the camera in the elevator
and say okay i know
that was tim and that's all i knew
but i was never i was never i was not
there and that saturday when that
happened i see i believe that
that whatever they happened they said it
happened when they called the police i
believe it was it wasn't a saturday and
i was not there
okay
do you recall who told you that on that
monday following
oh okay
as a matter of fact i think it was one
of the residents because they approached
me and they said
there was a lot of noise because the
person was working out on the gym that's
next to the penthouse
they heard a punching noise and that's
it and i that's why i checked the camera
and said and when i looked at the
cameras and i thought johnny like i say
was just walking back and forward and
the elevator
and i said like okay all right okay now
i'll try to figure it out and i didn't
say anything more i turned up the camera
and that's it
so the first part of that
somebody was working out and heard noise
someone was working out on the gym
and heard the noise to hear some a lot
of noise in the hallway
because it's really rare to hear
anything because most of the time
uh the penthouse level is is really
quiet
okay do you remember who the person was
in the gym
that heard a lot of noise in the
penthouse that name
that's correct i do remember the person
who is it
uh
i remember the person is been a resident
of the building for a long time
i just don't remember i don't remember
her name
and where is the gym
in comparison to
the penthouse
that's owned by mr deb
like i said johnny dev owns all the
penthouses on the on below the clock the
gym is sick the gym of the eastern
columbia building is just in front of
one of the penthouses
you actually can see it through the
window
you can see the gym through a window of
the penthouse and you can see the
penthouse through a window of the gel
you can see the the gym to
one of the windows to the penthouse
and it has a
patio that leads to the gym
and also that is to live to the gym
okay
and
this tenant if you if you think of her
name while you're you know even if we're
asking another question please let me
know this this tenant this is a resident
there right that saw this
did she describe
anything voices
any objects anything like that
no she's just saying there was a
noise
that's not just noise
and she was just surprised because like
i said it's always really quiet
okay
and so she wanted to know what happened
and so you went to the video cameras to
look at
video how did you know when to look for
them
because she got the time
she got the time that she was working
out
that's what i i i feared out of the
track the time on the camera it looked
and then when i saw as soon as i saw it
like i said johnny depp walking back and
forth the other i turned off the camera
and i figured out okay this is what
happened
i figured out put one and two together
it says okay
when you said you figured out what
happened after you saw johnny depp in
the elevator what did you figure out had
happened
mr romero i'm going to ask you
to look at this is a video clip
marked as romero exhibit number eight
okay
and it shows a
date and times
near the bottom do you recognize this as
the elevator at ecb building
that's good mr romero you're nodding is
this the video that you remember looking
at after shauna told you that she heard
the noise that night
that's correct
and that's mr depp
correct do you recognize the other two
men in the elevator
i recognize uh the guy in front of the
elevator button that's his personal
bodyguard
the other guy uh i've seen him before
but uh
i never interact with him
if i did i don't remember
you said he looked at him
yeah he looked sad today there like he
was walking back and forward he took his
jacket his body language it was a
different about than before
most of times he's really calm
he's just like really happy person
like this is the first time i saw him
like that
and then you go to the next so then you
say wednesday may 25th
at approximately 10 30 ms heard walked
into the lobby accompanied by ms raquel
pennington that's the person you called
rocky earlier do you remember her
yes that's correct
okay
and you said that mr bird approached you
to ask you for the key to her unit which
you gave
and you said we did not discuss anything
else at that time
all right
miss heard stood approximately three
feet away from you
i did not notice any bruises cuts
swelling red marks or any other injuries
of any kind on this bird's face do you
see that
all right
okay
but you weren't looking for bruises cuts
flowing red marks or any other injuries
on this hurt's face that night were you
i was not looking for any marks or
bruises or anything
but
something like that it will be really
noticeable
but i guess you know
i was not looking
i was more focusing on what my job
student was like getting the key
and also this
i gave him the key and they were talking
about i told her you know what your dog
i was talking with raquel because her
dog got out of her unit
and that was one of my concerns i would
tell you know what i saw your dog was
outside he didn't want me to get get too
close to it so it's still out there you
know on the penthouse area
their dog will be fine because it's not
like i said it's always really quiet and
mr deb owns everything up there so
it'll be fine so that was one of my
concerns that was my job and was just
taking care of that
i was not trying to say oh let me see
your face no
so
and that's where i'm going to follow up
do you remember what ms heard was
wearing that night
nope do you remember whether she was
dressed up
no
do you remember where she was coming
from that she was coming home at 10 30
at night with ms penny
no i don't remember they mentioned to me
she watched actually she was on the
phone she was with raquel in front of me
we were talking about it and then she
left to the lobby
where she was still on the phone
i was focusing more on raquel because
she they want i was telling about her
dog
okay do you remember what hairstyle ms
heard had that night
no
do you know what type of makeup amber
heard was wearing that night
no
can you tell me whether she was wearing
concealer or foundation
no did you tell me whether she was
wearing blush
no
could you tell me whether she was
wearing any type of
any kind of eye makeup no
so
who wrote
the sentence i did not notice any
bruises cuts swelling red marks or any
other injuries of any kind in this
bird's face i'm pretty sure if i want to
see something like that i would have
said something
mr romero i did it i didn't saw any
marks or bruises on her face i don't
just don't recall
just don't saw anything she was just
standing in front of me
i'm asking specifically i did not notice
any bruises cuts swelling red marks or
any other injuries of any kind to ms
bird's face who wrote it
that's what i
said i didn't sew any marks or bruises
on her face
that's what i said
because
they asked me
they asked me if i remember seeing
anything i said i just don't recall
seeing any marks or brothers because she
was just sitting in front of me
i just don't remember anything anything
just don't remember
how it would be so obvious like someone
had like
a black eye i would have like whoa you
know i would have seen that and i would
remember because
it's something that you will all you
will see
you're like so noticeable like you will
all like you will remember but when i
was there talking to her she was like
three feet away from me she was right in
front of me i just don't remember seeing
any marks bruises or anything
but you don't know whether she was
wearing makeup to cover it do you
no i don't know
i
she was wearing any makeup try to cover
it probably
you know
the probably would you probably will
cover any bruise
but you cannot cover the swollen
were you looking for swelling
no
i could say i was not looking for
anything in fact you were spending more
time talking to rocky about her dog were
you not
that's great but i gotta i gotta have it
uh when i'm [ __ ] someone i look into
their eyes
and when i was talking to uh amber and
rocky i always look into their eyes
and i will probably wouldn't notice like
any swollen
or bruce
like i said
i would probably would notice it's fair
to say mr romero
that you can't say that amber heard
had injuries or did not have injuries
that day on the 25th
i don't remember
i wouldn't probably remember the swollen
but i didn't saw anything
i don't
remember
and you don't remember seeing anything
right but do you remember
even looking
i remember
i remember okay i'm i'm really sorry
but i remember
i gotta tell the whole story how they
got there
before they got it they went and get the
keys they come down they say somebody
try to get into my unit
there's scratches on my door say
hey like
oh um i'm really sorry but
who
will think it's gonna get into your unit
because it saw some scratches on the
door like
what four inches
above the door because the dog was
scratching the door was trying to get in
and they thought about someone's trying
to break into the the unit
i said on my head i would say you're
really you think someone's trying to get
into your unit
this crashes like four inches above your
the floor on your door that was the dog
trying to get into the unit
they were so afraid oh summer's trying
to get into my ears like oh come on
really
and i actually went
they asked me to go inside the unit just
to check room by room to make sure that
no one was there so i did that it's part
of my job make sure they're safe but
i like really i didn't understand why
they want me to do that
like
oh i don't know
i just so stressed out because of this i
just don't want to deal with this
anymore i'm tired
i don't want to deal with this court
case i everybody got problems
and i don't want to deal with this no
more
[Music]
the interaction you just testified about
is amber hurd and rocky pennington
talking about the dog and going up and
checking out the penthouse none of that
was on video footage correct
that's correct that we don't have
cameras on the videos um it's sorry we
don't have cameras at the hallways
we don't have cameras on the hallway
i'm gonna show you
uh what has been marked as romero
exhibit number one it's a deposition
that you was taking of you on july 19
2016. now that's approximately two
months
after
the may 21 2016
incident
um and i do you recall giving that
deposition
extreme
okay
i'm going to take you to page 35.
a little bit more
you were asked
this is the same incident that you're
talking about now
okay
and it's talking about okay you spoke
with amber at the front desk later sat
in the lobby later went upstairs with
her
it says the question at line six i just
want to go back for a second here you
said several times in answer to my
questions that you didn't recall seeing
any marks on amber's face
when you say you didn't recall seeing
any of those marks any marks did you
mean that you didn't see any marks on
her face
and your answer then was i say that
because when i saw amber i was not
looking to see anything on her face i
was not looking to see anything do you
recall giving that testimony on the
under oath back at that time two months
after the incident
yes i don't i remember because like i
say i was i always make eye contact with
someone i'm talking to
but i'm not looking to find something
like like oh your makeup is wrong uh you
you haven't uh have changed your
eyebrows
or your eyelashes are not even or
i'm not looking for anything they're
just looking at their eyes and i look
i'm not looking for anything else but if
i see something i will probably remember
if you saw something right
yeah i would have probably would see
like if she had a swollen like if she
was wearing makeup probably will
dispense in the swan i'll probably will
remember that but i was not looking for
anything i was like no
how swollen was amber on the 25th of may
how swollen was her cheekbone
according to the pictures you i've been
seeing right now are you showing me
it was pretty swollen i will probably
will remember that how many days later
did you see her from that swelling
it was on a wednesday that was from time
to wednesday like how many days would it
be fair to say
that you cannot have to fight one way or
the other whether ever heard was
domestically
abused by johnny depp on may 21 2016.
i can't i cannot say that i was not for
not agreeing to testify against
anyone of domestic violence because i
was not there i didn't see anything i
didn't hear anything i was not there i
was never there i was probably hundreds
of miles away
and got no idea what happened that day
and do you remember
that there was pictures
of wine a glass of wine a bottle of wine
wine stains on the floor outside
of the
uh in the hallway of the penthouse from
may 21st 2016.
i remember trying to mark that i gotta
say it was wine
ladies and gentlemen the next portion of
this deposition contains questions asked
by council for mr depp
you sit here today
when you saw her at the front desk on
march 25th
you didn't see any bruising correct
all right
and you didn't see uh
that's correct i didn't see any marks or
bruises
you didn't see any swelling either did
you mr romero
that's correct
no swallowing she was only
and she was only three or four feet away
from you correct
correct
and you were looking right into her face
squarely correct
correct
and the lighting was
good at the front desk correct
it was so good that had she had any
bruises swelling or marks on her face
you would have noticed that correct
and then later that
later that same day
and you testified to this already today
later that same day you went
up the elevator with miss heard and miss
pennington
uh in connection with their request for
you to check the penthouse correct
and during that entire
period of time taking them up to the
penthouse walking through the penthouse
and then finally you leaving and going
back to your desk
you did not
you look you looked at miss heard during
that time period correct
that's right
and you looked her in the face squarely
in the face correct correct
and you didn't notice any swelling
correct
correct
i'm sorry
all right
i didn't saw anything
did
did you see did you see any swelling
no
did you see any bruises no
and again just to repeat when you were
previously when you were confronted
with the faith did you see any spelling
on her face
nope
nope
did you see any marks of any kind on her
face
at all
and how was the light down when you were
at the reception and you were looking at
her and didn't see any of this how was
the lighting
the ladder it's actually pretty it's
pretty good
it's not it's not talking at all
she was far away apart
of three to four feet apart
were you looking or square in the face
all right
okay
and when you were up in the penthouse
and you were looking her square in the
face how far apart were you from her
then
we actually were pretty close to each
other
uh
she was probably next just next to me
she was telling me like going to this uh
this um
this room so i need to pass right in
front of her
and
do you recall
seeing
any bruises swelling redness or any
marks on miss kurd's face on may 24
2016.
i'll see if anything
ladies and gentlemen at this point the
remainder of this deposition of this
witness uh contains questions by counsel
for ms heard
i'm going to talk a little bit about
the video clips that
mr depp's attorney
showed you
um
i'm going to ask you first of all mr
presidio showed you a number
of video clips from
may 24th do you recall
may
that
yes
but in fact you don't recall seeing
amber heard on may 24th correct
it's [ __ ] i don't remember i don't even
remember what i got for breakfast
okay
well let's pull up
exhibit number one
let's stay on page 17 that's a good
place
um this is your deposition from july 19
2016. do you recall that
nineteen yeah
okay and that's
three in the morning
okay and it said here
uh
did you so saturday was the 21st did you
work that day no did you work sunday may
22nd no did you work may 23rd yes on may
23rd while you were working did you see
amber at any time i don't recall seeing
that question did you work on tuesday
may 24th yes i did and
and on tuesday may 24th at any time did
you see amber i don't recall seeing her
do you remember that being your
testimony two months after the events
yeah
i just don't recall i don't remember
okay
um and then while we're here now mr
presidio had you go through a number of
video clips and ask you a bunch of
questions about whether you start
swelling whether you saw red marks
whether you saw all kinds of other
things
but in fact um i'm going to ask you and
tell me if you need me to bring up the
videos and replay them
can you tell me
what type of makeup amber heard was
wearing in any of those videos
[Music]
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing concealer in any of those videos
no can you tell me whether amber heard
was wearing any foundation in any of
those videos
no i can't tell
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing any blush in any of those videos
no can you tell me whether amberhead was
wearing any powder on in any of those
dresses no
no but
she looks really pale
well
do you know what shade of concealer or
foundation or powder ms bird uses or
used at that time
no
okay
um so you don't know whether ms heard
was wearing makeup in every one of those
video clips correct
all right
[Music]
so
the
incident was may 21st 2016.
you saw her the night of may 25th
correct
well and was she friendly to you in each
of these hundreds of times
yes yes i'm not gonna say no because she
was really always nice
all right
be nice all right this is my last
question you testified in response to mr
presidio's questions um that you
testified truthfully in all of these
occasions did you testify truthfully
truthfully to everything that you
testified in response to my questions
today
that's correct
i did
all right it's a good time to break for
lunch uh we'll just break a little early
so just don't talk to anybody don't do
any outside research and we'll see you
at two o'clock okay thank you
all right
that was the first i'm sorry
i will say your own that is the most
bizarre episode yeah okay all right
see i've just never seen that before
i've seen a lot of things but i've just
never seen driving that yeah that did it
all right so um
we will come back at two
is there anything preliminary before we
get to the next deposition
you'll work through them and then if i
come back at two we should be able to
take care of it pretty quickly yes yes
okay all right great we'll come back at
you thank you
what are you doing
what are we doing first we're doing
careers
are we ready for the jury
okay we are your honor thank you
okay
all right thank you thank you for your
patience ladies and gentlemen all right
your next witness
plaintiff calls christian carino your
honor christian carino and um as with a
number of the other depositions this one
will start with questioning by miss
herds council and um at one at some
point switch over to questioning by
council for mr deb all right and what's
the how do you spell the last name just
for me just okay c
a
r
thank you
an address for the record and you may
use your business address if you've done
feel more comfortable
christian carino and the work address is
2 000 avenue of stars in century city
and and that is in california correct
and what is your current occupation i'm
a talent agent
and
could you give me just a very brief
description of your educational
background and work experience
sure i have a ba from the university of
massachusetts
and my work background is i've been at
caa for approximately 16 years and
before that
i had
a
12-year
run with two different advertising
agencies in new york
and who were those
advertising agencies in new york
and mccann erickson
right
um now you indicated that you were
a talent agent can you please describe
what that means
um i represent
multiple clients and brands
um
in transactions in the entertainment
space
and
when you say
in the entertainment space what are you
including
just the different genres of
entertainment everything from
motion picture to television to
books to
licensing to
[Music]
modeling
all the different areas that the agency
is
operating
as a talent agent
representing multiple clients
what types of services do you perform
for them and what is the objective
okay
i
i conduct transact business transactions
on behalf of clients and brands
in the entertainment space
and
what does that mean
[Music]
it means
it means i
organize pitch
transact
in
contractual
agreements between talent
and
studios
talent and
brands
entertainment platforms and individuals
brands and individuals
do you represent any actors
i do
work with
every different group of
talent within the agency
and for each person it's different
the business that i personally oversee
for them
so in some cases
i am
negotiating
contractual
agreements
for a music artist to
go to las vegas
in some cases i'm transacting
an agreement
for an artist to have a relationship
with a brand
in some cases
it's
a an artist with a platform like netflix
it
it spans the
the general
platform
capabilities that the agency has overall
is one of the objectives of your
representation
uh to
build
uh the careers of the individuals you
represent
yes
did you have any
conversations with mr waldman in which
you
expressed
any thoughts or opinions
on
how you believed any litigation was
having an effect on mr depp's reputation
or career
yes
how many times
one that i can recall and when was that
i have no idea years ago
if you expressed to mr waldman that the
sooner the litigation was over the
better for mr depp
what were you thinking when you said
that why did you think that
i think any time somebody is in
litigation publicly
it is at a minimum a distraction to
that person's
career
and in
a lot of cases it's
it negatively
impacts
that person because there's the tension
drawn to them
that
uh it is outside of what people want to
know about that person
and
what do you mean by it distracts from
the career
i mean that
with somebody who is well known
people don't want to hear
they're in a lawsuit
with anybody about anything
why not
because that's just not what they want
to
know or hear
news about
people
[Music]
and why do you believe that
based on my
experience in
this world for the past 16 years
and when you say it negatively impacts
what do you mean by that
people don't want to hear that
the people that they look up to
are in
litigation
do you also believe that that impacts
career decisions by producers directors
[Music]
companies with brands things of that
nature
yes
and
in what way
because the general public doesn't want
to hear that
people that they look up to
are in litigation
and when it
the more oxygen it takes up
in
the
overall news
or coverage of an individual
and the less focused it is on that
person's career
the less interested
studios brands
the general public becomes in that
person
and therefore less opportunities
yes
when you expressed
to adam waldman that
your opinion that the sooner the
litigation was over from mr depp the
better
what did mr walden say
to be honest i don't recall exactly what
he said but something to
something like
we're
gonna get this over with as fast as we
can
mr carrino i'm going to ask you to take
a look at what has been marked as carino
exhibit number we'll keep it labeled for
um do you believe that the mandel
lawsuit
posed a distraction to mr depp's career
i i don't know
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as
carino
deposition exhibit number five
and as you can see here it's an article
june 21st 2017
the hollywood gossip
do you recall
that coming up during that time frame
that issue have you read or heard of the
rolling stones
yes
have you read or heard of gq
yes
mr carino i'm going to ask you to take a
look
at what has been marked as carino
deposition exhibit number two
and it's
rolling stone
uh
publication on june 21 2018
do you see that
yes
do you ever read this article
parts of it
aware
of whether
this article
in the rolling stone june 2018 that's
reflected in carino exhibit number two
impacted in a negative way
mr depp's reputation or career
elena i i don't think it's possible to
ask anybody
that that question
without
having done research
among the people who
read a specific article
if you're asking
my opinion
about whether an article like this or
this particular article in my opinion
would have a positive or negative effect
on somebody's
you know career
i could potentially answer that
but as to definitively whether an
article
has or has not had an impact on
somebody's career
nobody can answer that question
without research
specifically
mr carrito i think we were just going to
start looking at the carino exhibit
number three
this is an article that was
published in november of 2018
do you
recall
reading this at some point
what publication is that
this is gq
i
probably read part of it but i don't
remember
you had any direct contact with ed white
or his company
yes what is the nature of your contact
with
his company
payment on
on
deals where
johnny was owed money
bill collecting
when you say bill collecting was it
collecting on on your behalf or was it
trying to collect from studios or
companies
uh the latter and so what would your
involvement be in those circumstances
um ed
on occasion reached out to me to ask
about
the timing of a payment that was owed to
johnny
[Music]
were you able to answer those questions
um i think in all cases i just referred
him to somebody who worked for me to
find out what the payment schedule was
other than these
occasions where ed white would reach out
to you
to ask when payment timing payment did
you have any other
connection or communication with ed
white or his company in connection with
johnny depp
no
were you familiar with jake bloom
yes
do you know whether mr bloom ever
represented mr jeff yes
what was your understanding of the
nature of back representation
he was his lawyer
did you ever talk to jake boom
yes
on how many occasions
did you speak with jake bloom
relating to mr deaf
i have no idea
was it pretty frequently
what does that mean
well is it more than 10
are you asking me if i had
approximately
10 conversations with jake
over the duration of our relationship
yes
i actually asked if you had more than 10
i wasn't asking you if it wasn't zachary
okay
i mean i'm guessing that
it was probably less than 10 in total
was mr bloom still representing mr depp
when you started representing mr depp
i believe so but i'm not sure
and when did you start representing mr
depp
um i believe
it was
in
20
late 2016.
mr um carino are you looking at
something to be able to refresh your
recollection i am what do you have in
front of you
a note
that i made to myself of of
uh the date
of
when johnny was a client and i think i
wrote down october 2016.
do you have a recollection of the
context
of your discussions with mr william
yes
my recollection of the conversations i
had with
jake were
in regards to
uh getting
[Music]
johnny and
jake to
meet and work out whatever the issues
were
around their disagreement
so you were trying to broker
if you will a uh discussion between them
to try to resolve their issues
right
were you successful in that
i don't remember whether they ever got
together and
and
met about it to be honest
now i'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition carino deposition
exhibit number seven
and this is
a um
lawsuit that was filed on october 17
2017.
were you aware of this litigation being
filed by
mr depp
on his behalf against bloomberg
demur
yes
and
were you involved in any way in this
litigation
no
do you know
one way or the other
whether
the filing of and the ongoing litigation
associated with this lawsuit
had any negative impact on mr
depp's
reputation and career
i said now early
do you recall whether there was any
publicity surrounding
this litigation that's reflected
uh in the complaint that's number seven
are you asking me if i'm aware
if
the jade bloom litigation was made
public
yes
yes
and in addition to being made public
do you recall whether there was
publicity surrounding the jacob
litigation yes
and do you recall whether there was
publicity surrounding the mandel
litigation
yes
mr greene i'm going to ask you what has
been march's deposition exhibit number
10.
uh and in this particular one we have
this is the
article that
was written in the sun
times
that
was the
beginning
if you will of the uk lawsuit
do you have a recollection of seeing
that
no
did you ever read it
i don't know i'd have to
i i don't know i'm sure i've read at
least part of it if it's the
the original
document that caused the
sun
legal issues
now the date on this one is april 27
2018.
[Music]
do you see that on there
yeah
mr crater i'm going to ask you what has
been marked as deposition
carino deposition exhibit number 11
and it's dated june 13 2018. it's hard
to see that little scamp there at that
but it was filed on june 13 2018
um
and it's mr depp filing the news group
newspaper is limited who owns the sun
and then dan
[Music]
were you aware
that mr depp brought this lawsuit
in the uk against the sun and mr wharton
yeah
mr credo i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked now as
carino exhibit number 12.
this is a
this was published in the washington
post
on december 18 2018
were you aware of this article
yes op-ed
yes
mr karina when i asked you whether you
were aware one way or the other
whether
this
lawsuit that's reflected in
exhibit number 11
had a negative impact on mr
depp's reputation and career
you answered no what did you mean by
that
i meant that
there isn't a way for any individual to
know
whether the filing of a document had an
impact on somebody's career positive or
negative without
specific research conducted
in
exactly that
case
the same as in the facts that you
because you haven't researched it you
don't know whether it impacted mr depp's
reputation or career correct
i i believe
i stated that unless someone had done
research specifically about the filing
of this document
and
its impact one way or the other it's
impossible to answer the question
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as carino number 14.
this is the lawsuit that mr depp filed
against
ms heard
do you believe that the filing of this
lawsuit reflected
in carino
deposition exhibit number 14
and the attendant publicity has had a
negative impact
on the
reputation and career of mr death
no
and why not
because i've stated previously
it's not about
the filing
of a lawsuit it's about the coverage
i mean you're asking me what my opinion
is of what johnny's reputation is
today is is that
what you're asking
my opinion of what johnny's reputation
today is
one of the finest actors of his
generation
has
in your opinion has mr depp's reputation
changed
at any point
from october 2016
to the present
if you're asking me if what i defined as
his reputation has
changed in terms of
his being viewed as one of
the best actors of his generation
i i would say no
so just so i'm clear that i understand
your answer
in your
opinion
mr depp's reputation
is that he is one of the finest actors
of his generation and that has been his
reputation
since you started representing him in
october 2016 it still is today and it
hasn't changed during that time frame is
that correct
the view on his acting ability
has not changed
well i'm taking your definition
of reputation you said what they are
known for
so i'm taking that
specific
definition and i'm asking is there
anything other than
that mr depp is one of the finest actors
of his generation
that he is known for
that has changed between october 2016
and the president
the only way i can answer that is as it
relates to his professional capabilities
that has not changed
is there something that has changed that
doesn't relate to his professional
capabilities
i don't know how to answer that elaine
using your definition of reputation
which is what
a person is known for
is there any aspect
of what mr depp is known for
that has changed between october 2016
and the present
it's
i've
stated what i think his reputation is
and i've stated that
in my opinion
his professional reputation
as it relates to the quality of his
acting abilities has remained unchanged
do you
make any distinction between
personal and professional reputation
yes
and what is that distinction
the difference between
what somebody does on screen
and
off screen
what is your opinion of
what mr depp was known for off screen
when you started representing him in
october 2016.
i think
what he was known
for
off screen
was
a shroud of mystery of
who he was because he was not
visible
to
the public
and that was back in october 2016.
uh i don't have a specific date for that
all right but when you started
representing him that was your sense
yes okay
did that change
over time
yes
and
in what way did it change
[Music]
it
changed with the exposure of
that that came with the
lawsuits
and the lawsuits that we're talking
about are the ones
that
we've
already taken a look at
exhibit 4
7
8 9
11
and 15. no i mean 14.
i mean
i'm not talking about any
one or two
specifically
in general
do you believe that mr depp
is still a shroud of mystery not visible
to the public
no
and when did that change
i don't know exactly when
would you say it was cumulative over the
period of time as a result of all of the
litigation and the publicity ensuing
probably
is there any one specific litigation
that you believe most significantly
impacted
on mr depp's personal reputation no
longer being a shroud of mystery and not
visible to the public
my opinion is that amber's accusations
would have had the most dramatic impact
on
his off-screen reputation
i'm not talking about
any
one specific
accusation
when you say amber's accusations
what do you mean by that
i i mean the things that
she's accused johnny of doing
both
in
that have been made public
now
those accusations were made public in
the divorce back in 2016 correct
i don't know exactly
how or when they were made public
given
that you believe amber's accusation
would have had the most dramatic impact
on mr depp's off-screen reputation
would
amber have been filing the divorce
action
and obtaining a domestic violence
restraining order have had a dramatic
impact
on mr deb's off-screen reputation
i think the only way i can answer that
is
by saying i don't think
filing for divorce
would have any impact
whatsoever
and
i'm actually not familiar with the
lawsuit to get the restraining order so
i don't know
exactly what's in there
but
if
that was based on
claims of
accusations of
abuse
then that in my opinion
would have a negative impact on johnny's
offscreen reputation
mr carino we were talking about
amber's accusations
uh and your view that those would have
the most dramatic impact
on
mr
depp's
offspring reputation
and you were talking about her
accusations of domestic abuse and
violence correct
yes
were you aware that the dan wooten
article published in the sun
included
specific accusations
by amber heard of domestic
violence and abuse by mr death
the sun case is that what you're asking
about
well first the article itself that was
in the paper
why is jk rowling genuinely happy
about employing mr depp the wife peter
yes
okay
and you're aware that
the
the litigation the lawsuit including the
particulars of the claim brought by mr
depp
included
the accusations uh by amber heard of
domestic violence and abuse
by mr death correct
yes
given that the mandel lawsuit included
uh
accusations by amber heard of domestic
violence
by mr depp against her
are you able to say how much
of mr depp's off-screen reputation was
in that impacted by the mandelbox
now you were aware
that the op ed
by dan wooten and the son
included
accusations
by amber of domestic violence against mr
jeff right
yes
um
are you aware one way or the other
how much mr depp's
off-screen reputation was impacted
by the
complaint that was filed in this case
that
contained amber heard's accusations of
domestic violence and abused by mr depp
no
are you aware of how much
mr depp's offspring reputation
was impacted
as a result of
the op ed in the washington post from
amber perth
are you aware of how much
mr depp's off-screen reputation was
impacted
by the accusations
included in the waldman tweet
on may 220
of the op-ed
are you aware of any
role
or opportunity
that mr depp
lost
as a result of
the op-ed by dan wooten
no
are you aware of any role or
and when i'm saying opportunity any kind
of business opportunity
uh that mr depp lost as a result of the
particulars of claim
that mr depp filed
are you aware of
any role or business opportunities that
mr depp lost as a result of the op-ed by
ambro third in the washington post
are you aware of any roles or
business opportunities that mr depp lost
as a result of the walden tweet from may
2020 relating to amber's outfit
is there any other
goal
or business opportunity
that mr depp
has lost
since
you started representing him in october
2016.
and i'm saying i would say
his um
i would say yes
and what
the pirates the the next pirates movie
do you remember which one that was
six seven i'm not sure what the number
is
it's six i think pirate six is the one
that you have to come up here um and
why
what is your understanding of why
mr depp's lost pirate six
my opinion
is
that it was related to the accusations
that amber has made
and what is your opinion based on
excuse me
what is your opinion based on
um
conversations with
colleagues and studios
i'm sorry i didn't quite hear you
conversations with studios and other
executives both
internal and external
when you say related to the accusations
that were made by amber heard against mr
deb are you talking about
accusations of domestic violence and
abuse by mr death
yes
how many conversations have you had with
studio
and other executives
i have no idea
more than five more than ten
um
i don't know about more than ten
probably between five and ten
who do you recall speaking with
uh at studios
or other executives
um
jerry bruckheimer
probably mostly jerry and then
colleagues at caa
when did you first have any
conversations with jerry buchanan about
pirate six and just
i have no idea
whether it was in 2016
2007
2018 2019.
i don't
when did you have any conversations with
colleagues at caa
it would have been whenever the
decisions were being made about how to
cast that movie i don't i don't honestly
i don't know what year that was
do you recall who you spoke with at cnn
i spoke with jack wiggum
i spoke with
brian lord
what do you recall jerry bruckheimer
telling you
um
[Music]
i i don't recall the specific
conversations
but the
nature of it was that the studio was
having difficulty employing him
and did mr bruckheimer
tell you why the studio was having
difficulty employing mr duff
um
no not specifically but it was
understood
did you
ask i didn't need to
why did you think you didn't need to
because
everyone was aware of what
was garnering the
attention of the studios and determining
whether or not he could be employed
when you say everyone was aware
how do you know that
i i don't know i just knew
can you tell me who everyone is
[Music]
the the people who would have been
involved in
making that decision
well
if i'm understanding you correctly and
please correct me if i'm wrong
the only person that
disney that you spoke with about pirates
uh and employing mr depp was jerry
blackman correct
um
yes
right and you spoke between five and ten
times
with mr bruckheimer
and he did not say in any of those
conversations
the reason we're not employing mr depp
is because of amber ferd's accusations
of domestic violence abuse by mr right
that's good mr karina when we went off
for the break we were talking about your
discussion with jerry bruckheimer and
other executives at caa
um
respecting
mr depp not being employed further at
disney and likely not pirates
um and i think a question came up right
before the break
and so i just want to make sure that i
have clear
did you talk with anyone other than
jerry bruckheimer at disney about mr
depp not being employed again at disney
or pirates
okay and was i correct that you in a
certain understanding you had somewhere
between five and ten conversations with
mr brookhand
relating to this topic
um probably less than that i talked to
jerry regularly
um
but
probably not that many on this topic
okay and was there anyone else at disney
that you spoke with at any point
about johnny depp being considered for
pirates or not being employable by
disney no okay and that is that true to
the present
yes okay
uh and the other discussions that you
had
those were all with executives at caa
yes and that was brian lord and jack
wiggles correct yes anyone else
not that i can recall now
do you
you would indicated
that you believed that everybody
everyone was aware
um
that the
impact of
amber's
allegations were at the heart of this
uh
if i'm i just want to make sure that
we're clear since we were just talking
about this before the break
jerry bruckheimer did not say
specifically
what it was that caused disney to decide
not to continue with johnny depp and
pirates six or in other matters correct
correct
well and i'm trying to reach that it was
understood i'm trying to discover any
facts that would have led you to believe
it was understood and if i'm
understanding
use the same word mr bruckheimer didn't
tell you that correct
again it was understood so
i don't recall whether either of us ever
said anything specific about
why
but
it is something within the industry
that is
understood
can you
tell me whether
any other actors
did not receive roles
or
were unemployable because of the metoo
movement allegations
other than mr gatlin
not that i work with directly now
in any of your discussions with mr
brookhaven
did you ask him what mr depp could do
to become employable by disney again or
to be able to get any part of any
pirates
franchise going forward
no
why not
because
they're
in cases like this there is nothing
anybody can do it is the
directive of the studio to and they have
the sole right to
make the judgment whether they can
continue to employ somebody or not
and your understanding from your
discussions with mr bruckheimer is that
disney had made
the
judgment to decide that they could no
longer employ mr death is that correct
yes but but not
solely based on conversations with mr
bruckheimer it was cumulative
with the internal and external
conversations
what did
mr
lord say
that led you to believe that
but disney had made with the decision
the judgment that they did not were not
able
just just that the decision had been
made
what did mr wiggum say
about
making the judgment of whether they
would not be able to employ mr death
perfect same thing
just that they made the decision
correct
were you aware of any problems
on the staff with mr depp during the
filming of pirate's pride
are you aware of mr depp uh
engaging on alcohol and drug use being
tardy any of those issues during the
filming of pirate spy
um i'm aware of him being tardy but he's
been tardy on everything in his entire
life
[Music]
were you aware of whether that was
troublesome to disney during the filming
of pirate spy
i think it's troublesome to everybody
but
everyone
has learned how to produce a film
dealing to deal with
it working around mr gap
yes
do you know whether there was anyone on
the set of pirates 5 who wasn't willing
to deal with it and was quite irritated
about it no
were you aware
that
the filming had to be shut down for a
period of time
after mr deb injured his finger
yes
were you aware of any disagreements
between mr depp and disney including mr
bailey and others who were on the
project
about
artistic differences in other words for
mr depp thought something should be this
way or something should be that way and
they didn't agree
yes
okay what is your understanding of that
there was a difference of opinion on
how the film was edited
and what is your understanding of what
mr depp thought it should be
i i don't know how to describe the
difference between
the disney
edit and johnny's preferred edit
i think
johnny uh
told me about it talked about it a
little bit
do you know how well pirates five did at
the box office
not exactly
do you know whether it was it was more
successful or less successful than
earlier pirates
franchise
i think it was slightly less than i
wasn't the most successful
installment of that franchise
do you know whether mr depp has a payoff
play
clause
that would
pay him even if he was not in the
subsequent fight at 6.
in six
yes
i don't think he does
have
you or any anyone at caa on behalf of mr
deaf
made any efforts
with disney
to
[Music]
find any roles for mr depp
since
he filmed
pirate spy
my
efforts were
probably primarily around houdini which
at one point was a film
but
um other people at ca for sure did yes
[Music]
i would start with jack wiggum
um we'll now play volume two of mr
carino's deposition at which
okay
maybe time for afternoon sure he's close
enough absolutely all right before we
get to volume two let's go ahead and
take a 15-minute break please do not
talk to anybody about the case and don't
do the outside research
all right
okay
okay let's get sure
all right you want to continue with this
witness then
yes thank you your honor we'll now play
volume two of mr carino's deposition
which is the questioning from council uh
for mr depp okay thank you
you're aware that this litigation
involves a dispute between uh johnny
depp and amber heard correct
correct
and you know both of those individuals
correct
correct
who did you meet first
amber
when did you meet her
i i don't know
exactly when
but
probably within
the first few years of being at caa
okay
so can we as an estimate stay
2005-2006 time frame
sure i don't actually know but sure
but it was pretty early on at your
career in caa
correct
and describe for me the events of your
meeting her
um she was represented theatrically at
the time
by
an agent named warren zavala
who
has since left ca
and he brought her down to my office
because he wanted me to
represent her with him
specifically in the commercial space
and what do you mean represent her in
the commercial space
help identify
business opportunities for her with
brands
okay
so not as an actor
correct
and did you take on that representation
i did
yeah at some point in time you did
consider her a friend in addition to um
you two working together is that right
yes
and in that regard did you
uh you and her do anything social
yes
and can you describe for me generally
what types of activities you two would
do together as friends
we
would go to dinner go to events together
just hang out at
each other's
residences
and at some point at some point in time
did you consider mr deb a friend
yes
and
how did that relationship
evolve and i'm just talking about you
and mr depp becoming friends
i
spent
a fair amount of time with
both of them together
and at some point started to spend time
with him on my own as well
and at some point in time did mr depp
become a good a friend to you as miss
heard
i'm sorry let me let me re-ask that also
did you consider
at some point in time did you consider
mr depp a friend to the same degree you
considered misheard a friend
yes
and at some point
let me ask you at some point in time did
you uh represent
mr depp professionally yes and can you
explain to me how it how it came to you
representing mr debt professionally
johnny asked me to represent him
and when you began representing mr depp
did you continue representing this hurd
yes
and do you recall who mr deb's agent was
priority he was represented at another
town agency uta do you still work for mr
death
i do not
you recall when you stopped working for
mr deb
within the past two years
and um
can you describe the circumstances of
you no longer working for mr deb
he left
caa
to follow
an agent who
left caa
to become part of a founding group in a
new management company
and who is that person
jack wiggum
was mr wiggum ever affiliated with caa
yes
okay
and
say that when jack wiggum departed t.a.a
johnny went with him
yes
and
when mr depp left um
left caa
did you remain
did you remain friends with him
no
okay
well i should probably first ask at some
point in time
um
did your friendship with mr depend
yes
and when was that
i would say
at the time he left
caa
and did him leaving he had something to
do with uh the end of the friendship
i don't know are you still friends with
miss heard
no
and when did that friendship end
probably when
the
legal disputes started
and what legal dispute are you referring
to
this one
the
i'm not sure which one was first but one
of the disputes between johnny and amber
okay but it would
your friendship with
you're not referring to their divorce
correct
correct
okay so you remain friends with both of
them through their divorce is that
accurate
yes
although you're no longer friends with
mr depp do you have any animosity
towards him
i do not
and same question with respect to ms
hurd although you're not friends with
her any longer do you have any animosity
towards her i do not
do you recall when it is the last time
you spoke with miss heard
i do
not it have been around the same time
that um
your friendship ended with her
i would assume so
exhibit 16
no uh mr kareem
you'll see at the bottom here and let me
if you can see it do you see at the
bottom it has a bait stamp number under
the yellow tag cc0070
yes do you recognize this document
and take your time if you need to review
it
yes
okay and do you understand this to be a
true
uh an authentic copy of uh email
exchange in which you were involved
i believe so
okay
okay and it's you'll see it's dated
january 11 2018
and the subject is wme
do you know what what is your
understanding of what wme is
william morris endeavor
and what is that
it's another talent agency
okay
um
and you've you've read this email from
misheard to you correct
correct
so at this point in time would you
was she a close friend of yours
yes and ultimately did she leave caa
yes
and it was at this time
yes during the the entire time you
represented uh miss heard
did mr depp ever interfere
with your representation
of misheard
no
did he ever ask you to do anything
uh with respect to
um
her career
not that i can recall
except at 17
now mr carino this particular document
was not produced by you
you'll see that
at the bottom here
the bait stamp
indicates alh
that means it was produced by miss heard
and
this appears to be a text exchange
between you and her
it's about a page and a half if you
could take the time to read it and then
i will ask you questions about it
you'll see at the top
mr preno that it's dated
uh july 14 2016.
based on that date and based on reading
this text exchange
at this point in time uh
were you close friends with both mr depp
and mr
yes
and having read the text exchange
do you believe do you believe this to be
a
true and correct
uh representation of the exchange
yes
and to be authentic in that regard
yes
you start the text exchange by
indicating jd just surfaced who is what
is the jd reference
johnny depp
and she says i saw laurel yesterday
uh who is laurel
laurel's a therapist
do you know her full name
laurel anderson did you independently
know laurel
yes
did you have anything to do with um
laurel
seemed either
misheard or mr deb
yes
and can you explain that to me please
i introduced them all
and
was
what was the purpose of you introducing
her to them
they needed
help
and can you explain to me in more detail
what you mean by that
i think it was out of time where they
needed somebody to help
mediate the difficulties they were
having
and what do you mean by difficulties
the strains on their relationship and
in that regard um did you have
conversations with miss heard
about the state of her relationship with
mr death yes i'm trying to determine for
how long a period of time
uh did miss hurt have conversations with
you about the state of her relationship
with mr death
can you give me
a time frame
i would say
she talked to me about the state of the
relationship
from the beginning until the end
the entire time you knew her i'm sorry
the entire time you considered her a
friend
and how about mr dev um would you
how would you
did you have conversations with him
about the state of his relationship with
mr
yes
and were those ongoing during the entire
time you were friends with him
yes
you say they both confided to you in you
in that regard
yes
so back to this text exchange
where my cursor is um
you miss her and says to you yeah she
said that johnny and i need to talk
directly do you know who she is do you
know who ms heard's referring to there
that was your understanding after
reading this
yes
and then you ask her do you want to do
something tomorrow she says yeah
um
she says idp i do
uh
you say ha
okay
and then you say what is safe to do do
you want to come to my place for dinner
what did you mean by what is safe to do
it meant avoiding paparazzi okay
and then she says
it's so [ __ ] up i just want to tell
him that what they are telling him isn't
true what was your understanding of what
she meant by that sentence
i don't recall
mr garino while she's doing that
um
at the at the outside of this deposition
i asked you
if you recall being deposed about a year
ago in this case
um and you said yes is that accurate
yes
okay what i'm going to show you now is
the transcript portion of the transcript
from that deposition and who is mr
bruckheimer
jerry bruckheimer is the producer of
the pirates franchise and who is mr
wiggum
jack wiggum
was an agent
at ca
who worked with johnny
okay
and who is
mr
lord
ryan is one of the managing partners of
caa
and also worked
on johnny depp
and what was your understanding of
why
the pirate six um
job was not offered to mr deb
leo you're asking my opinion
yes
because of the accusations that amber
had made
and what i'm about to show you mr
corrino is a
article in the washington post
authored by miss heard you're going to
notice that
the article will be presented sideways
so you'll have to tilt your head a bit
uh
to review it
at 19. do you uh
first mr karina why don't you take
control and just
scroll through
the documents just a couple pages
is this the top of the next page
yeah when there's a jump like that it's
just at the top of the next page
um
my
yes
do
okay
mr craig have you seen this document
before
yes
do you know who wrote this document
yes
who wrote this document amber
amber heard
yes
and do you see there on this first page
of the document
it actually indicates that it's written
by amber heard on december 18 2018.
yes and you understand that this
document was
authored by miss heard and published on
december 18th 2018.
yes
and do you recall reading it at the time
it was published
no
mr uh crano i'm showing you an email
exchange in which you were involved
um it's just this one page i'll blow it
up so you can review it uh take a second
to review it please
okay and
let's start at the bottom of this well
you see at the top that the email ray
line is entitled johnny depp's jack
sparrow won't return the new pirates of
the caribbean movie
yes and this email exchange was on
december 20th 2018 correct
correct and do you recall that the
article you just read published by ms
heard was published on december 18 2018
two days before this
yes
now if you go to the bottom of this
email
do you see there is this link to an
article
yes
and it says
url defense
i'm sorry it says
movieweb.com
yes
mr carino what i put up next to the
email exchange that we've been
discussing
is an article
dated december 20th 2018
okay
so this article is dated december 20th
2018
the email sent to you by um
robin baum
is that same day december 20th 2018
correct
yes
who is miss baum
johnny's publicist
she's sending this article to you is
that right
yes
and then in response you say
um we were were we told this officially
from disney
and she responds uh
i'm sorry
jack wiggum responds no is that accurate
yes
sure
so you testified uh just
a few minutes ago that it was your
opinion that mr depp
lost
the pirate six movie because of
misheard's allegations is that accurate
allegations of abuse correct
yes
and
is this a demonstration of
when
disney made that decision to not
uh hire mr depp for pirate sticks
yes
exhibit 22.
did you ever see
mr
more physically abused misheard
no
did miss heard ever tell you that she
had been physically abused by mr death
no did you did mr depp ever tell you
that he had physically abused miss hurt
no
did you ever witness
any
injuries on misheard that would indicate
that she was physically abused
no
now again this is a few months after the
filing of the divorce papers
and the tro
and miss heard states to you i'll call
you right back sorry
and you say okay
she says is it too late to call
and you say just finishing dinner we'll
call you as soon as we walk out within
20
and she says please tell him
i love him
is that an accurate reading of the text
exchange so far
yes
do you know if at this time
uh based on your relationship with miss
hurt and mr depp
um
whether
miss heard wanted to reconcile with mr
deb
yes
did you understand that she did
yes
did
miss heard
based on your personal friendship with
miss her close personal friendship with
miss heard
would you say
that she confided in you
and what about mr yes
mr craig at some point in time
uh after ms heard
filed his divorce papers in may of 2016
um did she
make any requests of you to intervene in
the relationship between her and mr bib
what do you mean by intervene
it's just in let's start with assistant
communications between the two
same objections
can you explain to me what transpired in
that regard
walk me through
at some point around that time she
wanted
me to arrange for them to get together
in person
and
what did you do
after that was requested of you by mr
i
talked to johnny about it what happened
after that
he was reluctant
at first and then agreed
and then what happened after that
i mean it's a long time ago but
i remember
there was a fair amount of discussion
about
the tro
and how we would deal with that because
nobody wanted
johnny accused of violating the tro
as an outcome of
that meeting
and i don't remember exactly what we
did
but
amber at some point warranted that she
would never accuse him of violating the
tro to do the meeting
and
i set the meeting up
so just so i understand
you set the meeting up
at the request of mr
objective
um
and as part of you setting up
she told you that
um
it didn't matter
what i'm trying to understand what what
was the issue with respect to the tro
my understanding of a
restraining order
at least at the time was that
he couldn't go within a certain
distance of
her
okay
and what was her suggestion
with respect to that issue
in connection with
her wanting to meet with him
she
promised me and told me to relay to him
that she would never accuse him
of violating
the restraining order
as a result of agreeing to meet her
and i believe but i don't
recall exactly there were conversations
with
both
sides legally i believe at the time
um
to make it transparent to everybody that
this was happening
okay
and then what happened next
um i arranged the meeting johnny was
in
san francisco
um on tour
and i arranged to borrow a friend's
house
and
amber and i flew to
[Music]
san francisco and drove to the house
and
johnny showed up a few hours later
and did the two of them meet
yes
in the same room
they sat outside
okay uh how close to each other were
they
inches away from each other
and how long uh
were they out there talking for how long
were they out there talking
several hours
did you although you were out there did
you
were you in a position where you could
see them through a window or otherwise
yes
at some point in time the conversation
ended correct
correct and what happened after that
i
received a call or a text from
steve whose house it was
and
he notified me that
he would be coming back
to the house
within the next hour or so
and
i told
johnny and amber
and we decided to rent a hotel room in
san francisco
so that they could continue to talk
and did that in fact happen
and at some point in time you left that
house correct to go to san francisco
yes
and was it the three of you
no
johnny had security with
him and
we talked about the fact that they
it wouldn't be
a good idea for them to be seen together
there
so
johnny left with his security in his car
and i believe
amber and i took an uber
and what happened after that
we all met at the hotel
room
and do you know what happened after that
um they started arguing
and do you recall any details of the
organ
no
and for how long were you was this
argument had in a in a hotel room
yes
did you witness the entire discussion or
did you leave at some point
i left the next morning at
five
o'clock in the morning or six o'clock in
the morning
and mr carino um i'm showing you emails
over produced by you first uh the bottom
of the first page it starts at the
bottom of the first page the
string above it was redacted and you'll
see that it starts on august 7th 2017 do
you see that
august 7th 2017. yes having read it uh
can you determine who you're speaking
with in this text exchange amber hang on
let me ask you this
do you know whether or not um
miss heard ever
had a relationship with mr elon musk
yes
she did
yes so again it's dated
august
of 2017
and she says dealing with breakup
i hate when things go public
see i'm so sad
um
having reviewed the document again do
you have an understanding of what she's
referencing there
um i believe she's referring to breaking
up with elon you say seems like a press
release
you weren't in love with him and you
told me a thousand times you were just
filling space
what are you saying there
i'm saying
why would you be sad if you weren't in
love with them to begin with
and by him you're referring to who
elon
and at this point in time
um
were you still close friends with miss
heard
uh looks looks like that's the case at
that time yes
and was did she still at this point in
time did she confide in you about her
relationships
yes
okay
and you respond
i'm sorry she responds
i know but i wanted time to grieve and
recover
in my own time
is she still referring to mr muskar do
you know
your understanding i don't know whether
she's referring to johnny or to elon in
that line
okay in this point of time do you know
uh
what her feelings were what was your
understand at this point in time what
was your understanding based on
your experience with her
what was your understanding
um uh
of her relationship with mr deb
i
i don't believe
there was a relationship at that point
and
you say and you got that no she says
i hate that
yet again a man lets me fall on the
spikes by myself
you ask how so
she says
oops meaning
they are mad at me for leaving them and
put things like this out there
you say
like
sorry
she says like that
you say
you could avoid all this if you stop
dating uber famous people
you can be with a big man who isn't
famous
what were you um relating to her there
i believe what i was saying was
if you don't like being in the press
about your personal life then
don't date people that are famous sure
um you indicated that she moved on
immediately uh after jd
uh after i'm sorry after johnny depp to
date elon musk is that accurate
yes okay sure
do you have an understanding one way or
another whether miss heard and mr musk
were in fact dating at the time of the
san francisco reconciliation that she
asked you to set up i i don't know
whether they were dating
but they
had definitely spent time together
[Music]
do you
do you know how long after the san
francisco attempted reconciliation you
gained the understanding that elon musk
and mr were in fact dating
i don't know
exactly how long but not long after
do you know who she's
what was your understanding of who she
was referring to when she was said here
i love him
johnny based on this exchange did you
have an understanding at this time
whether miss heard wanted to reconcile
with mr duff
i believe
she did
and at this point in time she was still
a close personal friend of yours correct
yes
and at this point in time was she uh did
she consider you a confidant in your
understanding
i i think
yeah
okay just to uh
authenticate this document again mr
craino do you see that
it's referenced at the bottom bait stamp
cc indicating that you produced this
document yes
and um
if having read this do you do you
perceive this as a transgress copy of
the text exchange between you and mr ms
heard
yes
okay
and i will um
can you see the very top here it's dated
august 16th 2017.
ms heard states to you
i written so many notes
can you give him one
i don't know how or where to start
there's no way to begin and
all i have to say but i have so many
finally i am single clear in my heart
and mind i just want him to know i loved
loved him and that i am sorry
do you have an understanding of who miss
hurt is referring to here yes
and who is miss her referring to in this
text johnny
and what is she um
asking you to do here
she was asking me to
deliver
a letter that she was writing to him
and
did she also want you to and it says and
that i am sorry
uh what was your understanding what she
was asking you to do there if anything
i believe that was all in reference to
getting him
a handwritten letter that she was
writing or trying to write was it your
understanding at the time of this text
exchange august 24
the miss amber was attempting to
reconcile with mr deb i believe so
okay
and i know maybe this may sound
repetitive but
on august 20 at the time of this action
on august 24 2017
um you and her were still close personal
friends correct
i believe so
there's not much here at all um
mr carino but i didn't want to confirm
that this was a document produced by you
correct based on the bait stamp on the
bottom
yes
and
do you see it's dated september 27 2017
september 23rd
oh you're right i apologize
it's dated september 23rd 2017. and it's
a text to you that says god i miss him
do you have an understanding of
what
not
who ms hurt is referring to there
yes
and who's that
johnny
and do you see um at the bottom
the date of the text is june 9th 2018.
yes
okay
and uh it says i text him happy birthday
do you know who sent that and who the
him is i assume this is from amber and
she's talking about johnny you've had a
chance to review the whole document um
what is
what is it what does this appear to be
uh it appears to be the communications
around the time that we
set up the meeting
in
and who are these communications between
me and johnny
okay
and this first bubble
um can you tell if that if the blue is
you or mr deb
ah i think the blue is is me
sure earlier in your deposition uh at
the very outset i was asking you about
your representation of individuals
at caa you indicated that you represent
individuals that are both actors and
musicians
would you consider mr depp in that pool
yes
and you've represented your ca
representative both in connection with
his acting endeavors
and um
his involvement with uh the vampires
yes
and
was mr deb's participation in
hollywood vampires lucrative
no
uh do you know whether or not it was
something mr jeff mr depp enjoyed
yes
plaintiff calls laura wasser by
deposition your honor w
a
s
s
e r
thank you
will you please state your name and
address for the record
laura allison wasser wasser cooperman
and mandels suite 800 2049 century park
east los angeles california at 90049.
thank you what is your occupation
i'm an attorney at law and how long have
you been an attorney
26 years
you represented mr depp in the divorce
against amber heard is that correct
yes
and you are here under subpoena
yes
your practice has primarily been focused
on domestic relations in california is
that correct
yes
are you a member of any bar other than
california
no
during the period 2012 to 2016
was california a no-fault state with
respect for divorce the answer is that
california was a no-fault state during
that period
during the period 2012 to 2016 was
california a community property slope
with respect to the division of assets
in the divorce
yes
and what does that mean to you
a california as a community property
state and what that means to me is that
assets which were earned or created
during the course of the marriage
absent some other
theory of law applied be divided
equally
and
what do you mean by absolutely some
theory
or law applied i'm sorry elaine what was
the question oh a theory of law when i
say a theory of lie mean if there's a
pre-marital agreement if there's some
other
um it's not completely uh blanket
community property there may be
things that were earned from a separate
property source that would not be
considered
community property so i was just trying
to
provide
for the record
some exceptions to what would be
considered community property and
therefore divided equally
now if someone alleges domestic violence
or abuse against their spouse would that
change the amount they would otherwise
be entitled to under community property
laws
no
in obtaining
a temporary restraining order
what is your understanding of the
process
the moving party
files
generally with uh 24 hours notice
to the
person who is being accused of domestic
violence
a declaration and forms
with the court
and
requests a temporary
domestic violence restraining order
that will generally last no longer than
a 21-day period
when the defendant is able to make his
or her
arguments as to why such a restraining
order would be
inappropriate and
the temporary restraining order can it
be continued
yes
when did you first begin representing mr
death relating to his divorce within
behave
i believe it was in
december of 2015.
i'm going to ask you to pull up
document 1 wasser document 1 and let's
go ahead and label that as wasser
exhibit number one
ms watson i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as wasser
deposition exhibit number one
it is a letter dated may 24 2016.
it's addressed to jacob bloom
uh and it says re in remarriage of death
do you see that
yes
okay and it's from
samantha spectre
who indicates she's representing amber
heard
as of the time of this letter
had you made known to
amber heard or miss spectre or anyone
else related to them that you
represented muslim death
i don't believe so
did you
receive a copy of this letter from
someone
i believe so i think i've seen it before
so yes
did you receive this letter
on or around may 24 2016.
okay next page please
hang on
yes it was around that time
around may 24 2016
yes
did you have any communications with
samantha specter
in connection with this mother
yes
and when you say within days
could it have been the same day may 24th
the next day 25th
possibly i'm going to direct your
attention to the next paragraph it says
to this end please have johnny promptly
sign and return by friday may 27 2016
the enclosed notice of acknowledgement
received form
confirming service of the summons
petition law case cover sheet and blank
response did you do that
this letter was not directed to me
elaine
no i i understand it but it was given to
you correct
i believe so
and you were representing mr deb correct
yes
and
mr bloom did not represent mr depp in
connection
with the
divorce correct
correct
so once
mr bloom gave this to you
then
did you represent mr depp going forward
in communications with samantha spector
once we received this letter
our firm took over with representation
of mr depp in the dissolution action
i cannot recall
whether or not
the
request made was done by
friday may 27th but i believe that it
was
probably that notice and acknowledgement
of receipt somewhere with a date on it
now the next section i think is
something that you referred to earlier
said in addition we are requesting on
amber's behalf the following
and it talks it says appropriate
condensate like support
uh
did you have an understanding of what
that amount might be at the time that
you saw this letter
i did not have an understanding of what
appropriate pendente lite support would
be at that time did you ask spectre
i don't recall
i don't recall our specific
communications regarding her requests
do you recall
making any kind of counter to any of
these items
all i recall is that
without any notice to us at 8 30 in the
morning on the 27th
samantha spectre and her client went
into court and obtained a no notice
ex parte restraining order
had you had any communications
with samantha specter prior to her going
into
court on that friday may 27th
yes
how many communications have you had
with ms spector prior
following getting this letter and prior
to her going into court at 8 30 on may
27 2016.
i do not recall
do you have a recollection of whether
any of the communications that you had
with ms spector between the receipt of
this letter
that's dated may 24
2016 and going and miss specter going
into court on
friday may 27 2016
related in any way
to requests on your behalf on on behalf
of your client that you made
now
you recall having communications with
samantha specter
between may 24 and may 27
you can't recall how many and you can't
recall
the specifics of those communications is
that accurate
it's not accurate
and
in what way please tell me
i recall that we had communications
between the 24th and probably the 26th i
doubt we spoke on the morning of the
27th before she went into court i do not
know the content of those communications
and i do not know how many
communications were had
now on the
next paragraph it has a proposal for
private
retired judicial officers
ultimately did you and ms spector talk
about using private retired judicial
officers whether it was the list she
provided or any others
i believe so yes
and what do you recall
my recollection is that is in almost all
of our cases certainly those with high
profile
clients
we would have liked to take it out of
the system
ms spector was not willing to do that
with this case
what do you recall this specter saying
to indicate that she did not want to
take it out of the contract
i don't recall her saying anything
[Music]
now
after your understanding was that a
class dv tro was in fact obtained on
friday may 27 2016
by ms heard against mr jeff correct
that is my understanding
after that
did there come a time
that you or anyone on on
at your law firm
communicated with the eastern columbia
building concierge staff or management
were those the downtown lofts
the the penthouse marks yes
it's and if it's easier for you
everyone's been referring to the eastern
columbia building as ecb
would that be helpful at all
sure or we can if you prefer to call
them the penthouse moth building that's
fine too
now that we've identified them i
understand what you're talking about we
can call them whatever you'd like
did someone from my firm speak with
somebody uh at the
at those
buildings yes
and
who from your firm spoke with someone at
the buildings
and when
[Music]
i believe either i did or my partner
samantha klein or
an associate who is also working on the
case
lisa sutton from our firm
we also had co-counsel on the case they
may have been involved
as to when
i have to imagine it was sometime
in
june or july of
2016.
now you you indicated either you or
samantha klein or lisa sutton and you
also had co-counsel do you have a
specific recollection
of speaking with anyone at the ecb
building
i don't
what were samantha klein's
communications with the ecb building
i don't know
were
what were samantha klein's communication
with easy with the ecb building
okay and her answer was i don't know
what were what were lisa's sentence
communications with the ecb building
i don't know what were
your co-consuls communications with the
ecb building when i say ecd building i'm
not talking about the structure i'm
talking about the individuals who worked
there
and just so we're clear here you don't
recall any communications with the ecb
building staff as well correct you asked
me if i had a specific recollection i do
not
do you have a general regulation
i believe that at some point we
subpoenaed the building's records of
the uh
video
from the lobby and elevator areas
so i would imagine that the
communications would have to do with
those subpoenas
are you able
to testify to any
conversation
you
or anyone at your firm or your co-consul
had with the ecb building staff
i am sure that there were conversations
and communications regarding
[Music]
the production of
the subpoenaed documents
review of the subpoena documents
their compliance with i believe it was
miss spector's
subpoena
that was sent
uh our ability to review the video's
coordination of same but i don't have a
specific recollection
of any communications
are you able to speak to whether there
were any conversations
between you
anyone at your law firm or your
co-consul and ecb building personnel
prior to your issuing
the subpoena
also i don't believe that the subpoena
was issued by our firm
so you don't have a recollection
of a subpoena being issued
on mr depp's behalf
for the
ecb building
surveillance tapes
i don't know i know there was one issued
i believe it was issued by ms spector
let's talk about the videos that you
just referred to from the ecb building
staff
how did you and your firm or your
co-counsel
receive these videos
i don't recall i would imagine a like a
b file or something like that
now is it your recollection
that there was just one e-file that
contained all of the surveillance tapes
i don't have a recollection as to
whether it was one or seven or what i
just don't know
when you were talking about receiving
the video surveillance footage
on whatever whether it was one file or
seven files whether it was e-file or
whatever did you have any understanding
that you were not provided the full
amount that was requested whatever the
amount was
no
so you thought you
received whatever you were supposed to
receive is that fair
yes
what did you do
with the actual
surveillance video footage that you
received
i believe we kept it on the computer at
least for the next couple of months in
preparation for trial
i don't know where it is now
that's my next question
is there a time
that you
no longer possess the video surveillance
footage that was sent to you
by the ecb building
i don't know
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
what has been marked as washer
deposition exhibit number two and it's a
multi-page document um and so i'm going
to
scroll down a little bit but
you let me know if i'm going too fast
here um it's dated june 3rd
and it's to samantha klein she's with
your she was working with you on the
depth case correct
correct
okay and it's from samantha spectre
which you can see there and we'll show
you the signature later
um and it's litigation called
preservation of information
including
not limited to electronically stored
information do you see that yes
do you recall receiving this letter and
if you want me to scroll down and let
you read each page i'm happy to do that
first i'm familiar with this letter i
recall receiving it
and
did you receive this letter
before
you received the
surveillance
footage from the ecb building
um
i am not sure
well i think you had indicated that you
thought that it was in june or july that
you received the surveillance footage is
that still your best recollection
i'm
looking at the date and knowing the
chronology of the case it is
my best estimate that we received this
letter prior to the time that we
received
the video footage
ms wasser
what steps did you and your firm and
co-consul take to preserve the
surveillance
video footage of easton b
from the time you received it going
forward
i think
the absence of us doing anything to
destroy the video footage would be the
most i could testify regarding in terms
of steps that we took to preserve
the video footage
are you aware
of any destruction of the video footage
the surveillance video footage from ecb
up to the present
no i we probably still have it
have have you looked for it
no
have you been asked to look for it
no
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
what is now the march's washington
deposition exhibit number three
uh and it's dated june 6 2013
addressed to you
and it's from charles carter did you
have an understanding that mr carter
also represented anger heard
i did when i received this letter on
june 6.
and did you have an understanding that
mr carter was also asking you to
preserve
any evidence
yes
okay
miss blaster i'm going to ask you to
take a look at what has been marked as
velocity deposition exhibit number four
it's dated june 6 as well and it's the
charles carter
from your phone
and you are acknowledging we see that
the preservation demand letter from the
spurt as well as his
and you indicated
we are fully aware of our obligations
with respect to the preservation of
evidence
please rest assured that we intend to
comply with the preservation demand and
expect that ms bird will do so as
do you recall saying that in this letter
yes
and was this letter in fact from you to
mr harden
it was
because i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as loss of
deposition exhibit number five it's a
letter dated june 21 2016
to samantha specter charles carter
leonard levine i think it's pronounced
remarriage of death
and it's from
[Music]
samantha klein do you see that
and you are copied on it do you see that
i do okay and miss klein worked with
your law firm yes
and represented mr deputy as well
is that correct yes okay
uh i'm gonna go back up to the beginning
to call your attention to a particular
section
it says this letter shall confirm the
agreements we reached yesterday with
respect to the pending domestic violence
proceeding see that
and then we're going to go down to the
media
press and it says neither party nor his
or her respective council
representatives or agents so make any
comments in the media or press
pertaining to this dissolution action
the civil action pending against doug
spinel
and are any pending or future litigation
between or
and or involving the parties do you see
that
yes right does that
uh
accurately reflect the agreement that
was made between
the parties with respect to the
neighborhood and mr depp and
communications with the press
yes
do you know liz walton's
who liz walters
yes
and who is she
she is a reporter
or
i believe she works for her brothers
online media outlet called the blast
did you have any communications with liz
walters during the depth her divorce i
don't recall
[Music]
did you have any communication with tmz
relating to the deaf herd divorce
i don't recall
now
the
what do you recall what the date was for
the permanent
uh tro temporary restraining order
do you recall the date you said that
early on 21 days after the temporary
restraining order is typically the date
that's set for the hearing for the
defendant if they want to come in and
oppose it or if the
petitioner wants to extend it you recall
what the first date was
i don't but i would imagine it was
probably at some point in early june
all right and then do you recall that
date being continued
i do
how many times at least twice
possibly three times i think that the
final
date was at some point in august and we
settled
right before then
all right
alan can we bring up
number
document number seven
thank you
ms wasser i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as wasser
exhibit number seven
it is dated august 5 2016.
it is to you
from
samantha specter do you see that
yes do you recall did you receive this
but doesn't it say at the top that it's
protected under 11 52.
it sure does all i'm asking you is
whether you received it i'm not not
asking you about the substance
i don't remember
do you have any reason to believe you
did not receive it
i don't
lasser i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as
rossignol deposition exhibit number
eight
and it starts out
with an email from samantha specter to
amber on august 6 2016.
uh
do you recall
what was going on on or around august 16
it's divorced
in connection with the divorce
not specifically no
do you know who christian carino is
i do
okay who is he
he's an agent a creative artist agency
how long have you known christian colina
i've known of christian for maybe
10 years
were you aware that mr currino was
involved
in
organizing if you will or assisting mr
devin is hard
with uh
their own
meeting to try to resolve
their case up in san francisco
possibly that sounds vaguely familiar
you on the telephone
at any point while amber heard and john
depp were meeting
to discuss
attempted resolution
resolution of the issues during the
summer of 2016.
what was your question was i on the
telephone
yes were you on the telephone
where mr depp and ms heard
were in the hotel room
and were talking
no
were you ever on the telephone
when ms hurd and mr depp were together
talking during the summer of 2016. no
matter where they were
on the telephone yes
no
while he was with ms heard and miss
heard was on speaker that and you were
on speakerphone with the two of them
no
you recognize the
do you name the name on what joe sweeney
i do
and who was he
joe sweeney is a forensic accountant
who specializes
in family law forensic accounting and he
was ms heard's forensic accountant in
the disso matter
and was edward white
acting as the forensic accountant for mr
death
no
did mr white provide the documentation
that was then submitted to samantha
specter as counsel for ms heard
i believe
came from mr white's office also
probably
of note is the fact that mr depp changed
business management
shortly before or during the course of
the case so it is possible that some of
the documents came from predecessor
business manager
i'm going to show you what
has been marked as watson deposition
exhibit number 10
and i'm not going to ask you
any specific questions so i don't need
you to have to review it in detail
unless you'd like to you're certainly
welcome to spend as much time as you'd
like on it but i'm just going to go down
to the end of it
and i'm going to
ask if this
is the deal point memorandum that you
referred to that was finalized on august
15 2016.
since the party's signatures appear at
the bottom as well as miss vectors in
mine i believe that this is the deal
point memorandum that to which i was
referring okay
is there any reason to believe
that it is not the the final deal point
memorandum
now
ms wasser i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as washer
deposition exhibit number 11
and it's a series of
documents
an fl 150 for example
and then
that's page 404 and then it goes into
the next
part one of one
just trying to page through it for you
just so you can see generally
do you recognize this document
yes
could you tell me what it is please
it looks to be one of the parties i
guess mr depp's uh what we call in
california preliminary or perhaps final
declaration of disclosure there's
financial disclosure forms
ms watson i'm going to ask you
if you can
take a look at what has been marked as
wasser exhibit number 12
and it's a
many pages
i think it's 50 total
do you recognize this document
yes
can you tell me what it is
parties
avoided judgment for dissolution of
marriage
is there a specific amount
that was paid to amber heard as part of
this divorce
settlement and judgment
for objection talking i'm sorry
for her claims of domestic violence
including any crimes of assault battery
intention or negligence inflection of
emotional distress viable slander and
defamation
i don't believe that we segregated out
what the total amount was being paid for
did you make any effort to seal sbal
the records
in this case and i'm referring to the
case in front of us the
the
marriage or partnership of amber laura
depp and john christopher depp ii
filed in superior part of california
county los angeles
when you say sealed do you mean by the
court to ask the court to seal the file
yes
i don't believe so
why not
we don't do that
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
what has been marked as
deposition exhibit number 13.
and this is a subpoena
of you for this deposition did you
receive that
do you want do you want me to scroll
through it would you like to
no i i i believe that we received it all
right and and you are testifying
pursuant to this subpoena correct
i am
i'm going to ask you to look at what has
been marked as deposition exhibit number
14.
um and this is
for the corporate designee of washer
cooperman and
mendoz you see that i do for
today's deposition
is it your understanding that you are
the corporate designee on behalf of
wasser cooperman and mendel's speaking
today
yes
thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen i think
uh
giving the hour that'll be all the
testimony that you hear today okay so
we'll go ahead and recess for the day
make sure you don't do any outside
research and don't talk to anybody and
we'll see you tomorrow okay get some
good rest all right thank you
okay
and tomorrow then we'll be starting with
that other deposition
that's correct and how long is that or
approximately
two and a half hours i'll take care of
the morning probably for the most part
and then you have remote witnesses after
that is that correct
okay so you can get me the contact
information for those so we can get that
taken care of all right just remember we
do plan accordingly because i do need to
take lunch between 1 30 and 2 30 because
there's a graduation i have to speak at
so we're going to take care of that okay
all right thank you have a good evening
thank you
you
[Music]
you